What's up freaks?
Welcome.
Thanks.
Thanks everybody.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast.
Yeah,
that's my laptop.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast,
brought to you by audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
he can get a free audio book and a month
of free audible service.
Audible is a really awesome resource for
audible audio books for podcasts and
standup comedy.
All kinds of great shit.
It's,
um,
one of my favorite things to do in the
car.
I,
I hardly ever listen to music anymore.
I'm always listening to a podcast or
audio books.
It's,
it's,
it's an amazing resource to.
And it's also amazing for taking time.
That usually is wasted time on an
airplane seat and it actually can be
enjoyable,
you know,
he can actually really get into a book.
It's fun,
especially if they're good.
The actors are good.
It's,
uh,
it makes it really interesting.
It's a,
it's like reading,
but someone else does all the work.
Anyway.
Go to audible.com
forward slash Joe.
They have over 150,000
titles to choose from.
You can get a one free audio book and 33
days of audible service.
It's a very cool company and they've
supported standup comedy for a long time
and we're also brought to you by Goto
meeting and then what the fuck is that
Joe Rogan?
Exactly.
Goto meeting by Citrix is a,
an easy way to stay connected from
wherever you want from wherever you are,
whenever you need to.
All you have to do is just click on a
link,
turn on a Webcam,
and you're instantly connected to
whoever you're trying to get connected
to your team.
And if you're one of them business cats,
it likes to have meetings.
Business.
Motherfuckers loved to have meetings
because at least it gets them out of
their offices.
It gives them like social time,
like the regular just sit in your
office,
going over numbers and all that
bullshit.
We got to get some meetings going on.
So,
uh,
this is a nice way of having these
inevitable meetings and not having to
actually physically go somewhere that's
going to happen some day where there's
going to be no more traveling.
He just going to interface with people,
just going to step up some big gigantic
screen,
slap some shit into your head screws,
matrix style,
and just going to interface with each
other.
But until then there's Goto meeting by
citrix brought to you by centering.
It's um,
a really a interesting way to,
uh,
have,
meetings online and um,
the way they have it set up,
they'll let you try goto meeting free
for 30 days.
So for this special offer,
go to gotomeeting.com.
Click the try it free button and use the
Promo Code j r e,
so remember User Promo Code j r a and
you can try it free for 30 days.
And tell me how you like it.
Uh,
I want to try to.
Maybe I'll have a goto meeting chats.
I think that'd be fun to get 30 freaks.
We'll meet somewhere and uh,
someone will say something stupid and
someone will pull their dick out.
What happens if you plead out?
Can you,
what if a kid's porn girls will
eventually start using this?
That's the problem.
If you have anything like this,
you have any,
any kind of way,
those porn gals are very clever at
figuring out a way to,
uh,
get through the system to have their own
little,
a Webcam show.
I would think it would benefit them
greatly.
I wonder if it can't do that.
I don't know you.
This is,
these are some things that you are going
to have to find out for yourself.
All right?
Um,
this is weird.
Okay.
But unless he used Goto meeting with hd
faces.
Oh,
again,
so the,
this,
this is saying that the,
the,
the images are actually hd.
That's incredible.
So it's an opportunity.
What they're saying is as it's an
opportunity to look at each other on a
Webcam,
like really high resolution imagery.
It's not like just,
uh,
the,
the shittiness of the past.
When,
when I think about Webcam,
like any kind of conference,
I think it's like a horror movie or
talking to some duties in Antarctica and
he's like,
we've found the samples,
but there's an issue.
And those.
Yeah,
this is hd.
That's incredible.
All right.
We need to figure out a way.
We're going to get in touch with Goto
meeting and figure out a way to,
um,
just have one freak party session a week
with 30 people in it and just,
uh,
let people were anonymous masks and
yell.
Horrible words.
Anyway,
go to meeting,
use a code word Jr.
He also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com.
Go to o,
n n I t a on it is a Human optimization
website.
We basically sell shit to make your body
work better,
whether it's vitamins,
nutrients,
strength and conditioning equipment.
It's all shit that we think is really
good.
It's all shit that has been proven to
have some sort of effect either on your
body's ability to produce testosterone
or your body's ability to process oxygen
more efficiently.
Like shroom tech sport.
All of it is science backed.
All of that is explained on the podcast,
but always explained on the website and
we're running studies on every single
thing that we have,
so it takes a long time to do these
studies.
It takes a long time to get them
published,
but we've been working on it for awhile
and we're trying to have this as legit
and above board as is humanly possible.
One of the ways we do that is there is a
30 pill,
90 day money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the
product,
so if you try out any of the nutrients
like alpha brain or shroom tack and
you're like,
this is really wasn't for me.
Get your money back.
That's where we're trying to sell you
shit that you're gonna want to buy over
and over again.
We're trying to sell you the best shit
that is currently available and we're
trying to explain why it's the best shit
and then we're trying to get it
published and we're trying to get it
processed out there so the people kind
of understand like there's a lot of
different nutrients that have beneficial
effects on your body and if you combine
them correctly,
you can have a positive impact on your
cognitive function.
Meaning the way your brain works,
it allows your brain to fire better.
Sounds crazy.
It's also been praised recently.
Alpha brain has been for a.
It's eight and lucid dreaming.
Apparently these cats I've never
experienced.
Justin,
you have lucid dreams.
Depends on what your definition of lucid
dreaming is.
Legit wet dream.
Then it's probably lucid dreaming,
right?
I mean I've had dreams.
Where.
Have you ever had a dream when you wake
up in the dream?
Think you're awake?
Yes.
And then realize you're still.
Yeah.
That's a trip that's kind of lucid.
I think there's people though they can
get it down to the point where they can
travel like in.
They can actually like getting that
dream,
northern that dream.
No.
There in the world of imagination and
just travel.
They can do things like some like they
get really good at it.
Like it sounds crazy.
I and I'm talking,
I'm talking completely from ignorance
because I've never experienced it.
I've experienced states have it,
but I've never been able to like say I
am going to go fight a dragon if you
ever have a recurring dream.
Yes.
I've had a couple of recurrent james had
won this recurring dream.
That's really strange because it's,
uh,
it's about,
um,
it's,
I've wrote it down,
I called it a thousand teslas and the
idea was that instead of one nikola
tesla at the beginning of the 20th
century,
there was a thousand of them and these
motherfuckers are just cranking it out
together and there was these floating
machines that were flying around the
sky,
but everybody was still in the 19
fifties and 19 sixties fashion garb.
But the world was radically more
advanced and it was this basically you
dreamed about the jetsons was,
it was sort of like the jetsons.
It was more english for some reason.
Everybody had an english accent.
It was very,
it's a very strange,
every,
there's a lot of like proper,
like 19,
early 19 hundreds.
Behavior and dress cm punk shit.
Yeah.
It was really weird.
It's a really weird dream because it's
happened more than once and it's almost
like my brain is trying to process that,
you know,
me being a stupid dude,
and I see shit like I see people,
uh,
figuring out the large hadron collider
and figuring out some new bacteria that
they've developed that eats plastic and,
and I just think if it was me,
if it was up to me to run this fucking
crazy planet,
much of this work would get done.
Like how much of that absolutely none.
I would have never invented any of this.
And so I realized
a guy like nikola tesla comes along,
just one super genius out of this world
motherfucker who creates 100 different
things that change the world.
If that guy had a thousand other ones
like him,
it would have been an amazing
transformation of humanity.
It's just that he was so incredibly
unique.
This one guy,
and of course there was other inventors
and edison and hundreds of other
inventors,
in fact,
that we're responsible for a lot of the
other things that he actually used to
make his things.
I mean there's a clear chain of
intelligence,
but if there was a thousand of those
super genius motherfuckers that can just
pull these nutty ideas out of thin air,
I gotta tell you man,
I mean if you look,
if I would have told you and on a.com,
codename,
rogan,
whatever,
that's a car show.
I was having this conversation with
somebody the other day.
If I told you in 1987 that you would
have a little thing about the size of a
deck of cards that you carry around in
your hand and you,
the touch of a button can talk to anyone
on earth with it.
Video,
chat with people and access all the
known information in the universe.
Yeah,
no one would fucking believe you for 60
bucks a month.
It's ridiculous.
And not only that,
but it would also allow your government
to track every move you make.
Yeah.
Everybody can track it.
Remove your mic.
We will just see that there was a,
um,
an app that was,
I think it was in Brazil.
They had this app and they took it down
eventually.
It was an android app that allows people
to turn your phone on a listen
you and record you.
It allows,
allows him to hear everything that's
going on in the room and track you
through gps that they were using that
that's some of the shit that we're using
in Afghanistan and Pakistan.
That is some crazy shit.
I mean weird if you think about it.
I mean the phone's got it all.
Yeah.
Bluetooth do.
Did you,
have you ever followed any of the
stuxnet shit and the viruses that came
out around that time?
I can't think of the name of the other
virus,
but uh,
it was,
had to be designed.
They were saying the cia or is real,
one of the other.
But one of the things that the virus
would do is on a computer that was
infected with it,
it would search for any bluetooth
connections in the area.
So if your phone had the bluetooth on,
it wasn't protected,
figure connected that bluetooth,
it will connect to that phone.
This is a computer with a virus on it
will connect to a phone,
download the address book,
all the contacts.
All that shit and then upload it to a,
a cash site basically,
where then they could come and get it
and then it would also wait for
instructions.
Yeah.
Sick.
It's not science fiction,
bro.
I mean this shit's incredible.
Shit happens.
It's,
it's real.
When you saw that michael hastings
junior,
the reporter that drove 100 miles an
hour,
did you,
did you freak out?
I,
you know,
I mean,
yeah,
it's,
is it,
I think there's some people in this
world,
you're probably better off.
Not fucking with.
I mean,
even if it's an accident,
you know,
I mean,
when you have people that kill your
nation's enemy for a living,
you really want to cross that.
You really want to fuck with them.
I mean,
who knows what kind of technology they
have.
If they can do that with a phone with a
virus that was engineered either by,
you know,
some superintelligent dudes from
whatever country and they can do that.
What else can they do that we can't do?
But that's.
I think that's where this recurrent
dream just kept coming from that.
I'm so fucking stupid.
I know.
I'm so fucking stupid,
like in comparison to all these people
that can make these laptops and make
these phones and figured out these
viruses.
I am so removed from the ability to do
that.
But you know what the to me the thing
is,
yeah,
you're okay,
but a lot of race car drivers don't know
how to build a car either.
It's true.
Yeah.
And to me that's one of the things.
The biggest thing would like what I do.
I mean,
the way I make my living now,
and I started with photography before
digital camera.
It wasn't for digital cameras.
I would've never picked up a camera if I
would've had to pick up a camera and
then go take some goddamn film and have
it developed and do all this bullshit.
And you know,
every time you made a bad shot it costs
you a quarter.
I mean there's no fucking way I would
have stuck with it,
but because of the tools,
this is a perfect example of it.
You know what I mean?
Look at what you've created out of shit.
You buy off the shelf.
You know,
it's a toolkit that allows people out
there to create things and we've seen
that now with,
you know,
film,
anything,
you name it,
the bar to entry is no longer technical.
You know,
40 years ago if you wanted to make a
film,
you were fucked if you didn't have a
bunch of money because it costs that
much money to do anything now,
you know.
So to me,
the guy who makes it,
yeah,
he's a fucking genius,
but the guy who takes that tool and then
expands on it and creates new things
with it,
there's just a smart,
well it's good.
It's just what they,
you know,
those people do though.
I mean they build off of each other and
that's where the,
the thousand tesla idea came from is
like if you had a thousand of those
motherfuckers communicating with each
other,
but if you had a thousand means nothing
to figure out with the rock,
maybe I'll figure that out.
Eventually find a sharp rock and I'd be
like,
I need to figure out how to make these
on my own.
Yeah.
I was driving out here from vegas and I
had never seen this.
It's been a while since I made the drive
and I don't know if this fucking
facilities new or what,
but coming out on 15 on the right hand
side of the road,
I saw this.
It looked like a giant fucking pond or a
lake or something like that.
And then there was a big ass tower
sticking up in the middle of it.
And this is in the middle of the desert.
Like,
what in the fuck is that?
Finally I figured out it's one of those
solar farms.
Have you ever seen one of those?
And I think this is how it works.
I need to google this shit and find out
exactly what it is.
But um,
it looked to me like in the big ass
tower because I've seen some things
where these solar farms,
they have all these mirrors and they all
focus on this center tower and then they
turn that energy into a,
I guess heat or however the fuck they do
it.
Oh,
I'm looking at these images.
Google images or solar farms.
I didn't even know this existed and uh,
for California it's a fucking crime.
They don't use it.
And I'm sitting here and I'm thinking,
I'm like,
why isn't this fucking desert covered in
solar panels?
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
but then again,
I guess if you look at how much,
how much fossil fuels does it take to
create something like that and then,
well,
how long is the break even point to
where it actually is making sense.
That's a good point that people don't
recognize that it takes a lot of fossil
fuels to make things,
make plastics to make everything,
you know?
I mean just drive the trucks to get the
shit out there.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's a really,
really,
really important point.
But I guess even with,
um,
I mean,
isn't it possible to make a lot of
things without it though?
I mean if you used electricity only from
solar power to make machines that ran on
solar power,
you know,
I don't know man.
I was,
I think I was thinking when I saw that
solar shit,
it got me thinking about oil and one
thing I've always had a thought about it
was after nine slash 11,
I think the one of the biggest fuck ups
bush had was he had the opportunity for
kind of a manhattan project moment.
I think if he would've came out and
said,
look,
we're getting off oil as much as
possible because it's not a green planet
issue.
It's not a tree hugger issue.
None of that to national security issue.
Because if you look at most of the
bullshit our country's gotten involved
in the last 40 years,
it's for oil,
which I'm not against.
I mean oil.
I mean it is a national security thing.
People who say,
well no,
blood for oil,
okay,
pay $10 a gallon for gas and watch your
fucking economy crash,
you know,
so.
But to me that was,
that could have been a manhattan project
moment or something similar to where you
make a giant breakthrough and because
this country has always proven that if
you,
if you pointed in the right direction
and give it a mandate and then back it
up,
perfect example,
moon landing,
the apollo program,
they started with nothing.
I mean literally nothing and 10 years,
not even 10 years later in that decade,
you know,
there was a man on the moon.
Well,
depending if you believe on that or not.
But uh,
yeah,
my point is humans can get,
we can,
if backed against the wall,
we can get some incredible
things.
She would have used that as a mandate to
say,
look,
this is a national security issue.
You know,
we're gonna.
But it would be your sounding like he's
like a real president.
Well that's true.
Well,
I'm just saying the opportunity.
the opportunity was there,
so the opportunity was there.
But unfortunately that opportunity,
it could have been capitalized on people
other than the people that were
monopolizing the natural resources.
And that wasn't going to happen.
The real issue is always money because
the money's being monopolized right now.
The money's being such a mass mass
amount of wealth that's connected to oil
that it's almost if you let people
control that,
the amount of money they have,
they could have a giant crazy army and
the year like you have to be really
careful of that and it's,
it's,
it's a shame that you know,
when you drive from vegas to California
and you see those gigantic fucking open
desert fields where there's just
nothing.
Those could all be just filled up with
solar panels.
They could just be plugging cars in.
The cars they have now are getting
close,
like they have that tesla model s yeah.
That's getting really close.
I mean,
it's crazy.
What other technology do you use this
100 years old?
Yeah,
in your life.
Think about it.
Can you name one fucking thing you use
day to day?
That's 100 years old air conditioning.
Not 100 fucking years old situations on
other users,
100 years old and the internal
combustion engine,
but do you think that it's the most fun?
The problem with those electric engines,
I've never driven an electric car.
They're missing something.
They're golf carts,
they're missing soul.
I did watch god.
What the fuck was that car that guy
made?
I forget where I saw it,
but a dude.
I'm high performance electric cars.
It's kind of a hate.
Does a handle thing.
Cars like a 100 grand or some bullshit
like that.
But the numbers on it are sick.
Is that the tesla roadster?
No,
this is a hand built thing this guy
makes.
Oh really?
Where the fuck did I see that?
I can't remember.
I'm terrible with that.
But anyway.
Um,
the numbers on it are crazy and it's
just like the torque.
There's no lag.
There's no nothing.
It's instant.
You know,
everything's electric better.
Yeah.
So it's just sad.
It can be better,
but he was actually running eighth mile
drags with it.
Wow.
And uh,
it was pretty slick,
but very fast.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
I don't know,
you wonder.
I mean,
it's got to go there.
right.
What seems like it's going there,
but it tried to go there before.
Do you ever see that documentary who
killed the electric car?
Yeah,
I think there's gotta be something
better than what we're doing this
burning ship and you know,
that's how you get things done.
It seems like really stupid at this
point.
But.
So does this nuclear thing.
That seems like a really stupid idea to,
you know,
I'm not educated enough on the nuclear
thing.
I hear both,
but if you look at it takes.
It's kinda like the old joke that you
know,
you can build a thousand bridges but
suck one dick.
Remember he was a bridge builder.
You can build a thousand nuclear plants
would have one fukushima.
But the problem is this,
it's been a few.
There's three mile island.
There's the fukushima and is it four
mile,
three mile island for 3:43
mile island?
Yeah,
I,
as I said before on the podcast for
apologies,
ladies and gentleman,
I'm fukushima and those are two a.
And I'm a turnover.
That's three.
So there's three spots.
Did you can't really,
you russian nuclear plants are just bad
fucking ideal.
Everybody's nuclear pants a bad idea.
But my russians come on man.
But my point was that you,
you're dealing with less than 100 years
of use.
Sure.
You already have three spots that are
completely ruined forever.
Forever.
Like longer than people have ever been
alive.
Right.
You know what,
you go back 100,000
years ago.
What did that dude look like 200,000
years ago?
Was that even a person?
You know,
if you ran into that thing running
around naked eating fucking squirrels
with his face,
that's barely a person.
And that's how long from there to now
where it's like,
that's like anybody can go back and have
a picnic and you'll still get sick.
Sure.
You know,
it's still not healthy.
It's not like living near a fucking
fresh spring.
It's creepy,
man.
I haven't kept up with the fukushima
shit.
I heard it's bad.
There was now I don't know about the
radiation and all that shit,
but they were saying that um,
there's actually debris now washing up
in Canada on the west coast and shit
like that.
It's made its way all the way over here.
Yeah,
it's really weird.
It's um,
it's not just that they,
they,
there's an inevitable loss of this water
that they use in the cool down the
reactor,
keeps getting into the ocean that's
getting into the ocean,
the tune of millions of gallons.
So they send the water in the cooler and
then pump it back in.
It's not even that they pump it,
it leaks out.
There's a lot of leakage to trying to
develop a system of holding it in place.
Now involves drilling these giant holes
deep,
deep into the ground and then inserting
this machine that essentially permafrost
the ground.
And so there's like tubes and you would
freeze these tubes.
So there's a,
there's all these holes in the ground
and then around that you had placed this
machine that freezes the shit out of
everything.
So it's a giant containment wall,
millions of gallons containment wall for
keeping in this insane nuclear water
waste.
But the issue is of course you have to
keep the power on this machine on.
And the whole point with you guys fucked
up was your power went off and then he
couldn't cool the reactor down.
So you're doing another thing based on
power,
right when you've already been sort of
been shown that we have these ideas of
what mother nature can or can't throw it
us and it's only based on a limited
window of time that we've been measuring
it less than a few hundred years and
even,
you know,
200 years ago,
who the fuck knows what kind of shit bag
equipment they were figuring out what
the wind speed the wind was when it was
coming and they didn't really know.
So that's a blink of a fucking eye in
terms of the world and how,
how the weather changes,
you know,
the weather can shift radically there.
It can do some really crazy shit.
So for you to count on,
you being able to keep the power on is
just ridiculous.
You count on being able to turn it back
on.
Yes.
I'm sure you'll probably be able to turn
it back on,
but count on keeping it on.
And if you don't keep it on what happens
that thaws out and all the fucking
nuclear water,
a trillion gallons goes flooding into
the fucking ocean.
Yeah,
that's a pretty big risk.
That's a big bet.
It's weird.
It's just weird.
It's a weird that we're
boiled down to that.
It's like,
how did this.
This seems like a chess game that
someone treated like checkers,
right?
It's like they figure you,
can we make it?
Let's fucking do it.
Can we do a nuclear power plant?
Let's do it.
Let's just make it.
Hey,
we can do it.
What happens if power goes out?
That's human nature,
man.
We've been doing that shit for,
you know,
since we came out of the cave.
Yeah,
but this is one of the most dangerous
examples of it.
The idea that you could just completely
poisoned the environment to the point of
like if you were an alien dvt,
it would look like venom.
Ddt.
Yeah.
I mean fucking cigarettes,
tobacco.
I mean how many millions of people is
that killed over the years and it's just
humans aren't the brightest,
sharpest knife in the drawer when it
comes to shit like that.
How much better are there certain
cigarettes?
How much better those things?
I don't know.
I don't know anything about.
I've never smoked and I don't,
uh,
I don't know anything about that stuff.
It's one of the more dirty aspects of
politics is a,
you'll never see a politician talk about
cigarettes.
Too much money,
man.
Too much gas,
as many taxes.
Isn't that amazing though?
I mean,
what a weird commitment to something
that poisons people think about if
you're a politician or if that's.
If you're in the business of government,
here's an item that no matter whenever
you get into a tough spot,
you just fucking pass a sin tax.
You know,
cigarettes and booze.
People will bitch,
you know,
they like,
they won't buy it.
Yeah.
You know?
You tax it further,
trying to prevent this terrible plague
and that's how you spin it in a way
we're trying to prevent this terrible
plague is by managing millions and
millions of dollars from it and then
thus being connected to it.
An extra blade.
Yeah.
They don't ever let go of money.
Once they figured out a way to make
money from something,
they just keep the law the same.
It's very difficult to create laws that
stop politicians from making as much
money to cut their money back in certain
situations like this.
This idea that that's the will of the
people,
so fucking stupid.
It's creepy fucking organization we
have.
It's a.
I don't know man.
It's.
I liked the idea that our country
started out with that.
You know,
when you went to government,
it was service.
It wasn't a full time.
It wasn't meant to be a full time
position.
We weren't meant to have senators with
40 fucking years.
Seniority in the senate.
It was meant that you went,
you did your service,
you represented your district or your
local area and you know.
Then you went home
and the next guy went.
Yeah,
and we've turned into like basically any
other longstanding country with a ruling
class and they put rs and ds in front of
their names to give somebody something
to hang onto the vote for.
It's all the same shit.
Not only that,
they absolutely provably force out the
other parties.
Absolutely provably make it much more
difficult for them to be involved in
debates.
If you look at the coverage of anybody
that's outside of the standard,
two choices,
the coverage from they learned from ross
perot tell you what ross perot and
billion dollar monkey wrench in there
fucking plans and folks who were young
and full of life.
He don't remember.
Ross perot,
ross perot costumers.
Bush's second term.
Yeah.
Ross perot was a bad motherfucker.
That's why clinton won.
He came around.
Ross perot came around and all the
sudden there was this billionaire dude
explaining how the government works,
explaining the federal debt,
explaining the,
the,
the federal bank explaining taxes,
and you're like,
wait,
what the fuck is going on?
He took out time on network television.
That's what so gangster brought him
because he was before the internet.
This was not going on when everybody was
online.
This is like early nineties.
Yeah.
You know what was I remember year?
Was it the clinton?
The election was 92,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Ninety two.
Yeah,
man.
I remember my friend john was helping
with his campaign and it helps with
anybody's campaign.
It's like,
this motherfucker's going to get rid of
all the crooks.
He was so excited about them and people
are excited about ross perot was like
the original ron paul,
right?
But ross perot was way more gangster
because he had all that cash and the
money and how do I talk and saying,
here's the problem.
The crazy old fuck from down in Texas
can tell you.
That was.
Yeah,
that was a real interesting thing.
So from there they changed the
commission for presidential debates or
whatever they call it,
which is a privately funded institution,
you know,
corporations back it.
It's not.
It's not like it's a government program
so they can decide who gets the debate,
who doesn't.
There's a ross.
What's crazy?
I process in Washington where after have
started for a while,
you can't.
She hadn't become a foreign lobbyist.
Make $30,000
a month,
then take leave,
work on presidential campaigns,
make sure you've got good contacts and
then go back out and if you just want to
get down to brass tacks,
first thing y'all to do is get all these
folks.
They've got these one way trade
agreements that we've negotiated with
the ehrs.
Say us.
We'll take the same deal we gave you and
mail gridlocked right at that point
because for example,
we've got international competitors who
simply could not unload their cars off
the ships if they had to comply.
You're saying if it was a two way
street,
just couldn't do it.
We have got to stop sending jobs
overseas.
Probably a good thing.
He didn't win no business paper.
Otherwise we'd be occupying China right
now.
$14 an hour for a factory worker and you
can move your factor south.
The border,
high dollar an hour for labor.
Hire young 25.
That's assuming you've been in business
for a long time.
You've got a mature work for you.
Pay a dollar an hour for your labor.
Have no health care.
That's the most expensive single
element.
Making a car,
have no environmental controls,
no pollution controls and no retirement
and you don't care about anything but
making money.
There will be a sucking sound going
south so we.
If if the people send me to Washington,
the first thing I'll do is study that
2000 page agreement.
Second row.
Alright,
one last point here,
I've called out,
I decided I was dumb and didn't
understand it,
so I called a who's who of the folks
who've been around it and I said,
why won't everybody goes south?
They say will be disruptive.
I said,
for how long?
I finally got them up for 12,
15 years,
and I said,
well,
how does it stop being disrupted?
And that is when their jobs come up from
a dollar,
now they're $6 an hour and hours go down
to $6 an hour.
Then it's leveled again.
But in the meantime you've wrecked the
country where these kinds of deals.
Holy shit,
thank you.
Ms dot,
dot,
dot.
Holy shit.
Ross perot was calling shit in 1992.
He was a gangster.
I mean he.
How correct was that though?
What's funny is he was just talking
about the auto industry.
I spent 10 years in the auto industry.
I worked for ford motor company for
almost a decade.
And uh,
I took a buyout and they are,
our plant actually closed a few years
ago that I worked at in indianapolis.
But that industry is not the same and
it's gone and people in.
Yeah,
there's a lot of shit with the union and
you know,
you can argue both sides of that and
it's like most things,
there's no somewhere in the middle is
the truth.
But you know,
that whole way of life for a big part of
this country that auto industry was,
you know,
that was,
that is the middle class,
that was the middle class,
you know,
you could go to work for one of those
companies or one of the companies that
supplied that industry and work 30 years
and raise a family and your kids could
have a better life than you.
And that's all gone now.
Yeah.
There was a possibility for a guy to get
a really good job without an education.
Just,
you know,
you could get a really good job that
paid really well and you could have a
good living.
You know,
you could have a boat,
you could ever,
you know,
you'd have toys you could have,
you could have a whole vacation,
cars
and,
and you could,
you know,
I mean like when I was there,
if you just worked a straight 40 hours,
you'd make about 60,000
a year.
Now,
60,000
a year in Indiana or the midwest is
decent money.
If you worked overtime you could get up
80 to 100 grand,
but you could,
if you worked your ass off seven
twelves,
all the overtime you could get,
you could top out at about 1:20,
but that's literally living your life in
the plant seven,
seven days a week,
12 hours a day.
But they do that.
Yes.
And I'll tell you what that was.
I'm glad I did that because I was able
to see that culture of.
And then there was a long,
there's a long history there of,
because at least with ford motor
company,
nepotism was a well established thing.
That's how they did business.
They hired sons,
they hired daughters,
you know that it was,
I was third generation for ford motor
company.
I worked with guys.
I literally worked with three
generations of the same family,
grandfather,
father and son.
Um,
and it's,
what years were this?
This was I hired on in 1997 to December,
2006 is when I left in December,
2000 dollars just from the mustang.
Started getting good again,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Figured it out after all those years,
but it,
uh,
it and there was a lot of institutional
memory and it was the only place I've
ever worked where people at a factory
environment because I,
I'm from the midwest and I always worked
in machine shops,
tools,
tool and dye places,
stuff like that.
And that place you are proud to work
there.
You are happy to work there at least in
the beginning.
But I mean a lot of people.
That was the,
that was one of the ways they define
their lives.
They were a uaw ford motor employee and
it sounds silly to people who have never
don't understand it or anything like
that,
but you have to realize you're talking
about people that they weren't,
they didn't have to wake up one day and
make a choice between being a doctor and
being an auto worker,
you know,
that wasn't their fucking options on the
table there.
Options on the table or be an auto
worker,
be able to send your kids to school and
have a nice life or go out and scramble
for six and $7 an hour jobs for the rest
of your life.
You know.
And that's so guys you bought into that.
They bought into that whole dream,
that thing of,
you know,
and the company pushed that,
we're in this together company and union
and you know,
quality and all this other shit.
And people bought into it.
And that was why there was such a big
backlash when people figured out that,
you know,
no matter what the fuck you do on the
line,
it's not going to make a difference.
If the asshole up in detroit decides to
build a dog shit car or,
or decides to like go buy fucking jaguar
and lose hundreds of millions of dollars
on shit like that.
And so that's how plants get clothes.
And,
and not only that,
it's just a co,
we lost our plant because all this shit
went to Mexico.
Wow.
I mean it got to the point and the
reason why our plant started,
I wouldn't say in 1958 was when it
opened.
Um,
when you have a plant that fucking old
eventually,
you know,
it just gets to the point where it costs
more to fix shit than it does to move it
somewhere else.
So why would you spend $200,000,000
rehab in a plant that's 50 years old
when you could go down to Mexico,
get out from under all the fucking
retirement,
all the,
all the bullshit that you know,
he has accrued here for right or wrong.
And so they just finally were like,
fuck it,
we're done.
So what four did was they actually
formed a company.
They kept all their plants that
assembled cars under and they called
them ford plants,
all their plants that built parts.
If you didn't put a car together,
if you put a car together,
you were afforded employee.
If you didn't,
they spawn all their parts plants off,
which didn't generate money.
They were actually.
So they spend all their parts plants off
to a company called visteon.
Gm did the same thing with delphi,
so they spend all these plants off and
they say,
okay,
you're on your own.
Now we're going to give you your own
company and you're going to have to go
out and you have to make your own money.
Pay your own bills,
but here's the fucking trick.
These were four plants on monday.
On tuesday,
they're visteon plants,
so now they're on their own.
They're on the open market.
They have to make their own money.
But guess what?
They've only got one customer ford motor
company because that's who they made
plants that they were for it on monday,
right?
So they were always made parts for them.
So now what happens?
Ford comes to these companies before
they knew they were losing money when
they spun them off to make parts of the
cost that ford was paying,
and four,
it says you're going to have to do
better on the price.
We're going to have to cut you off.
And these were all ford people and so
what happens is now they start cutting
and it just,
it was,
you know,
it was a long way for them to close a
bunch of plants.
Gm went through the same thing and
that's how they justify the moves to
Mexico.
Yeah,
it,
it's,
you know,
it was why did the car suck?
You know,
the cars.
I think a lot of it had to do when I was
there,
the cars were dog shit in the eighties,
you know,
it's cool quality.
I mean it was Japan brought in the
quality aspect of it and you know,
the old saying,
don't ever buy a car assembled on a
friday,
you know,
you ever hear that?
You know,
that was detroit,
that was America,
that was the american auto industry in
the seventies and eighties.
And then they would just fat living high
on the hog.
I mean they were just,
you know,
you'd hear stories about these guys,
they used to have show up,
no show jobs to where at one time our
plant and had like 5,000
employees there when I worked there we
had like 2100 and we were doing more
work than the guys did in the eighties
with 5,000.
But they would have guys,
they would have,
they call them break off jobs.
So say you're working a 10 hour shift,
you would go in,
you would go in and work two hours and
then you break off and the other guy
would come in and he worked two hours
and he'd break off and you do that.
So because of what it was,
each job at a set rate.
So.
But the thing is they send on
understanding you.
What do you mean by break off?
Like you say you're line,
okay,
and you've got to take this fucking cup
and put it here,
pour some shit in it and then put it
there.
What they would do is they would say
that's a two man job,
so one guy would take this cup and he
would set it here,
the other guy would pour some shit and
then move it here.
Now eight hours a day.
Well one guy can do that.
So for eight hours you got two men on
this job.
I would tell this guy,
go get lost for two hours and then I
will do both jobs and then he comes
back,
come back,
and he would do both.
And so that's how you do the eight
hours.
You actually only work for exactly two
shifts.
Yeah.
And those were called break off jobs and
the plant was rife with them.
That's interesting.
And then they went through and they
killed all that shit,
which they're supposed to.
So I can go to the gym,
got so fucking bad guys.
We're only doing a day on a day off.
They would come in,
run their car to show they were there
and then jet.
And then you know,
one guy worked monday,
tuesday work wednesday.
So you can understand in some ways,
oh,
it's brutal.
Need to get rid of american labor.
Right.
So at that point when it gets that bad,
yeah,
there has to be a correction.
And I also lived in Kentucky and I saw
when toyota came in,
there was no before I worked before when
I was a kid I went to college in
Kentucky and then the summers I worked
for a toyota parts plant down there.
So I saw that side of the auto industry
before I ever saw the big money union
side and the way that worked was equally
as fucked up.
But on the other end of the scale,
what they would do is they would hire
temp workers.
Okay.
And they would go in and you would do,
you know,
assembly work or wherever the fuck it
was.
And they would dangle this idea of a
full time job in front of you.
Now this is in southeastern Kentucky
where if you could make $15 an hour in
1993,
you could live.
You can own a house because the shit,
I mean,
$40,000
a year.
There's a great wage because there's
nothing.
It's walmart or nothing or you know,
you sell weed,
that's it.
And but what they would do
is it would hire these temps in say,
look,
you got a 90 day probation period,
you can work if we like you,
we'll hire you,
you get benefits,
you get all this bullshit problem is.
And they hired you through a temp
agency.
Problem is they never fucking hired
anybody.
They've worked for 89 days and then say
we don't need you tomorrow,
send you home and bring another guy in.
So they never hired anybody.
Oh wow.
They just kept their employee filled
with temps and then you know,
they would find there are certain
positions where they needed,
you know,
supervisors,
quality guys,
shit like that.
Skilled positions and they would hire
those people full time but grounds on
the line and shit like that.
I mean you were cannon fodder.
It's really interesting because there's
like a cause and effect.
There's,
you know,
there's things were out of control,
but the,
the counter effect of that is to just
not have it up here at all.
Yeah.
This is really interesting.
It's,
I don't know where,
to me,
what it is is it's,
it's basically,
it's just we were losing the middle
class.
We've lost it and I can see both
arguments for that.
You know,
it's,
I'm kind of a guy.
Like now what I do,
I go work in casinos and I have to work
with unions and it makes me want to pull
my fucking hair out.
It's the most brutal shit in the world.
Did you see the culinary unions in front
of the tropicana screaming at people in
a video?
I put it up on youtube today.
Dana.
Dana white.
Let me know about it.
This culinary union has been trying to
keep the ufc out of New York,
new york's the last date,
last hold out,
and it's all because of the culinary
union,
culinary and spend a shitload of money
trying to consider the station casinos
here because the same company that owns
the ufc own station casinos and they're
non union and in their employees voted
for them to be nonunion allegedly.
Right.
According to the information that I've
read,
I shouldn't say allegedly I should say
to,
to the best of my knowledge,
they don't.
They didn't want it to be union.
They would have to pay union dues.
If you get paid well by your company,
you don't have to,
you know,
use what they were like yelling at
people while these people were going
into this casino.
They're telling people not to go in
because the casino's not union,
so they're being bullies.
They're,
they're bullying people that are walking
into the casino.
That's just so.
It's so unfortunate because it used to
be the unions were there to make sure
that people have a good wage and protect
your rights and make sure that you can
know.
You get a fair share of your,
you know,
your effort.
That helps build that business.
It's a great idea,
but like all great ideas,
sometimes they get contaminated with
comments and that's constant.
The fact that people found out that it's
a way to make easy money.
Well,
the amount of money that they would win
if they had station casinos turned union
is like in the millions and billions a
year.
It's not even as much money as it is,
as much money,
but as much as it is money,
it's power and influence and.
Yeah,
and voting.
I mean it really is a national thing.
I remember every time because I was
always.
I mean I'm.
If I had to put
a label on myself,
I'm right.
You know,
I would,
I would lean conservative,
I will lean to the right,
but I don't identify with either party,
but the union,
all,
every election would come up and they
would say,
look,
you got to vote for the democrat no
matter what because if not these
republicans,
they're gonna take your job,
they're going to rape your children,
you know,
they're going to put your wife in the
basement.
And they were just.
And they were a single issue thing.
And to me,
you know,
okay,
yeah,
if I vote for this,
I bought from my job,
but I'm also a voting against almost
everything else I believe in.
So.
But if I.
And if I don't go that way,
then you're going to call me an asshole.
And I'm supposedly a union brother.
You know what I mean?
But if I decided to go a different way,
now I'm a prick.
Well,
that becomes a problem in almost any
organization when you have very
controlled,
you know,
you have a controlled environment where
it's not based on the opinion of the
masses you're,
you're supposed to go with the way that
the head of the snake wants to go.
Exactly.
It becomes a problem in every single
organization.
As soon as you.
There's some sort of a struggle,
rules or sat down,
everything becomes defined.
Now it's an ideology.
Now you're part of a tribe.
Now it goes bad.
It's just we don't do good like that
man.
When it's us versus them,
it's almost always,
it turns out shitty.
It's like you've got to realize there's
no them.
It's,
you know,
we make everybody us because it's,
it is possible as a human race to make
everybody else doesn't have to be an us
versus them.
It's just you have to find out the
elements of society that are
problematic.
And figuring out how to fix them or root
them out.
But you know what,
I think since time began,
somewhere there was a fucking cave man
standing on top of whatever the hill
was.
It had the best shade and the cleanest
water and you know,
and that's all day if you look
throughout the world.
I mean in America we've been able to
pretty it up,
sand the edges off,
you know,
we make it look nice and uh,
but it's the same shit.
It's exactly the same shit.
When you see obama decrying the use of
chemical weapons,
think about how many motherfuckers have
died by drones.
It's like,
come on,
son,
that's ridiculous.
Well,
you're doing is.
It's okay to use robots to shoot
hellfire missiles from the sky,
but it's not okay to use chemicals.
Come on.
You're being silly,
man.
Yeah,
it's,
I,
and I agree.
It's,
I tell you what,
man,
I was really surprised that you got to
hand it to putin for how he handled that
situation.
He's gangsters.
I mean,
he made obama look like a child.
Well,
he makes it.
Obama look like a child on a regular.
Did you,
did you hear about the time they met at
this conference?
We're supposed to be at this conference
in obama's people wanted the gym at the
same time that putin wanted the gym and
there was a scheduling conflict,
so putin said,
I don't give a shit,
let them have the gym.
So he went swimming in the lake,
outside of the gym.
Pooter jumps in the lake and he's doing
laps in the fucking lake out there with
nature while obama's aerobics scrunchy
socks.
Puente is gangster as fuck.
He goes fly fishing,
bare chested fucking buffaloes.
And yeah,
he's a savage and I don't know if that's
good or bad.
I don't know if it's good or bad.
I guess it's bad if his enemy.
There's a great documentary that I think
it's the canadian broadcast cbc did,
I think it's called the putin.
Putin,
putin,
whatever the fuck his name is the putin
system and it traces his history from
the time he was in college to now and
how he got to where he is.
And uh,
we'll get that greetings from Russia,
south selfish in it.
Shit.
They had some bastard.
And while balding somehow manages to
carry it well,
but that program,
I guess when he was,
uh,
in high school,
he went to a kgb office and said,
I want to be in the fucking kgb,
and the kgb said,
we'll tell you he was going to be in the
fucking kgb,
but if you are,
this is what we're looking for.
So he went to college and basically
followed the guidance he was given.
And sure enough they tapped him when he
was in college and he went into the kgb,
the old school,
this is Russia missiles pointed at us,
you know,
and uh,
but that's how you got to start.
And people that are fucking smarter than
me that have been all over the world and
I paid attention to what they say,
all say that this guy is a problem.
I mean,
he's going to be a fucking issue.
And if you look at what he's done the
last 15 years,
you know,
I mean,
he was president of Russia and then term
limits kicked in or whatever.
And he was like,
okay,
I can't be president,
I'll be fucking prime minister.
And so he has a b,
he,
alexis,
buddy,
you know,
president or whatever his term ends.
And he goes,
okay,
I'm going to be president again.
So I mean,
this guy,
he's just,
he's,
he's a fucking gangster and he needs to
be respected.
But there's a notice in the us.
It's like there's this feeling that all,
he's a cool guy,
you know,
he's,
he's not a cool guy.
Well,
there's a lot of confusion in the us
that's amongst
a,
what I'll call progressive kids.
Um,
it's a young people that their heart is
in the right place and they are,
they have some good ideas about the
inequalities of the world,
but they approached them in a very
strange way.
Like people in progressive people will
consistently talk about islamophobia and
they will talk about how,
you know,
the,
the restrictions on people's religious
freedoms that are muslim,
uh,
people,
that are islamic,
that this is like a really horrendous
piece of racism.
Yet they will openly criticize
christianity.
Oh yeah.
Openly,
I'm a mockingly
criticized mormonism,
openly mockingly criticize in.
And it's like as any smart person would
know,
blank,
you know,
and,
but yet islam is because these people
are brown because the idea that they had
been marginalized because many people
that are from that culture are not
violent at all,
just like many christians are not
violent at all.
And they should not be defined by the
most radical,
the most radical aspects of their
religion.
I agree with that wholeheartedly.
One hundred percent.
But I don't ever see progressive people
getting on people for making fun of
christians.
It's like,
it's directly a part of the program.
Got to have their whipping boy,
you know.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
That was kind of one of the things that,
uh,
I don't know what it is in this country.
It seems in particular with the whole
fucking hipster thing,
which,
you know,
but it seems like,
when I was,
and I don't want to get into the um,
uh,
because I am getting to be an old
motherfucker.
But you know,
to me when I was raised up,
it was,
you know,
you,
you were taught that it was okay to be
proud of where you're from or where you
grew up and their struggles and,
and you know,
you were taught fucking history,
you know,
I mean,
I look now,
I talked to some kids like high school
kids,
friends of mine's kids that are 13,
14,
15 years old.
And I asked them,
you know,
just about any kind of american history
and some of the shit they tell me just
blows my fucking mind.
Most of it is what they don't know,
you know?
And then they all know almost nothing.
Right?
And how it's all being tilted.
And I'll tell you,
here's a perfect fucking example.
There's a great video I was watching and
it was a guy giving a talk on the
constitution and he asked,
he had a room full of this guy.
It was a,
a class and a firearm school.
So you've got a bunch of right wing
fucking,
you know,
the left would say,
god loving gun toting these guys,
you know,
constitutional guys.
You would think so.
He says he starts off in the ass,
you know,
basically named me the four members of
the simpsons family.
Everyone in that fucking place could
name him all four members of the
simpsons.
He said,
now named me the four rights,
guaranteed you under the first amendment
of the constitution and nobody could do
it.
These are adults.
I couldn't do it.
I could name me three,
but I couldn't taste the fourth.
What are they?
The right to petition your government
for redress,
right to assembly.
Freedom of the press.
Freedom of religion.
Huh?
Those are the four rights.
Guaranteed you under the first
amendment.
Isn't it fascinating that even back then
they were engineering against tyranny?
Fuck yes.
They will know.
They were like,
listen,
this kid get back like we have a good
idea right now and we're,
we're,
we're establishing in here right now,
but this could get back if it gets
infected with the very concert it right
now.
Go back and you look at the shit they
did and what happens is everybody,
you know,
the people on the other side of this
marginalized it because they say,
oh,
well they owned slaves.
Oh,
well,
okay.
Four fifths of a man or whatever,
you know,
in a marginalized,
all the good shit by the bad shit.
You know,
and,
and that's true.
Yeah.
Some of the shit they did didn't make
sense,
but that doesn't mean the shit that they
did do that does make sense is
irrelevant.
Well,
it doesn't make sense today and that's
what people have to understand.
There's things that we do today that
will be considered barbaric a thousand
years from now.
There's no doubt about it.
There's privatized prisons will be
looked down upon with incredible
contempt and scorn.
Privatized prisons will go down in
history as one of the most ignored,
horrific injustices.
The idea that people can profit and and
that they can spend their money to make
sure that people get locked up more
often so that they can profit.
It's incredibly insane.
There's a lot of shit that's going to go
down in our future into the future of
human beings where this day will be
criticized openly for human rights
violations,
all the shit that we're,
we were talking about earlier where
you're allowing people to work in a
foreign country,
third world country for a fraction of
the amount of money that it would take
your key in ensuring poverty,
you know,
taking full advantage on disenfranchised
human beings that's going to be looked
in the future upon,
you know,
they're going to look on that.
That's a horrific thing.
Just like slavery,
but
you know what,
at the same time,
uh,
you know,
if you're a guy in China and your
options are maybe starve to death if the
fucking rains don't come that year or go
work for,
you know,
a dollar a day and a nike factory and
living in a dormitory and work your ass
off from dawn to dusk,
but you're going to eat,
you know,
it.
It's,
you know,
one of the best things that I was
watching.
I forget what the fuck it was,
but a guy wasn't thomas friedman.
Um,
maybe once friedman,
but he was talking about like what's
going on in China right now?
It's like the last 100 years of american
history all going on at the same time.
Wow.
Because you're going from the grid and
certain parts of the country.
It's going from an agrarian society,
you know,
to where basically it was almost
subsistence farming,
you know,
they would raise crops,
it would sell and that's what they did.
You went up,
you work every day so you didn't fucking
starving the winter.
And then you've got other parts that are
going through almost the early 19
hundreds with the industrial revolution
and all the problems go through that.
And then you go to certain parts of it
and it's cutting edge 21st century
technology and finance and everything
else.
But you've got all this going on in one
country and that's,
you know,
that's kind of like a microcosm of
what's going on all over the world.
When you go to these certain places like
Malaysia or Bangladesh or some of these
other fucked up countries,
you know,
can you blame a guy for going?
And so in shoes for a dollar a day,
if there's another option is to starve
to death.
No,
I,
I totally is the guy who comes and
brings that job,
you know,
is he a complete fucking asshole for
doing it or you know.
Yeah,
no,
there's,
there's that argument.
It's like many things in life.
There's no real black and white.
There's a lot of.
I don't know the answer.
I mean it's like,
to me,
I see if you're a hardcore capitalist
than,
and I believe in capitalism,
then it's,
you know,
then you,
if the smart that can adapt and
improvise and adapt will,
will prosper.
And if perfect example like me,
you know,
I mean I was a fucking auto worker and
it was,
it was a mindless job.
It was retarded how much money they paid
us to do this shit.
I'll be the first one to tell you $32 an
hour to take this and go like that.
I mean over and over and over.
It was fucking crazy and benefits better
than almost anyone in the country from
the time I was born until december of
2006,
almost never paid the doctor bill.
Wow.
Because I was covered under that
program.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
Eyeglasses all pretty much free.
I mean,
just everything.
How much more money must be they've been
making now and they were making back
then.
The profit margins are supposed to be
insane.
You would think.
I mean,
I haven't kept up with the auto industry
because it was one of those things to
where I lived it every day,
you know,
it was you at one point when I was
there,
you could ask the dumbest toothless
looking motherfucker on the floor what
the stock price that day.
And he could probably tell you,
wow.
Because there was profit sharing.
Wow.
The stock was up.
We're getting a check.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
But uh,
and everybody was like,
you know what?
And mexicans not going to get a check.
They get a dollar an hour and no check.
The rest of that money goes to us.
One of the things that they used to tell
us,
and I don't know,
I've never seen a fucking mexican auto
plant,
but they said that one of the biggest
differences when you looked at a mexican
autoplant compared to an american
autoplant mexican auto plants don't have
parking lots because their workers don't
have cars.
They don't drive the bus.
They bused them in or they want
something happened.
Man,
I don't know what the fuck happened,
but something absolutely happen in the
design aspect of american cars where
they went from the coolest looking
fucking things of all time to shit in 10
years called,
I think it was corporate.
If you go back and you look at the cool
fucking cars,
so we're done with the corvette.
Carroll shelby,
you know,
if you're a weirdo,
you go into the fifties.
Yeah,
if you're a weirdo,
but if you're a
regular guy who appreciates a muscle
car,
you stay in the sixties to about 73.
Oh,
seven.
Yeah.
Well that was the.
Was it cafe?
Was that what it was?
Was having three.
They came out with that fucked up
chevelle,
chevelle that looked like shit with the
mustang
two and all that bullshit.
And like the early mid seventies.
But that was insurance and gas,
you know,
it's right when they made them put in
the.
You couldn't have a car that got for me.
Yeah.
They,
the catalytic converters.
And on switching to unleaded gasoline,
that was all that harmed the muscle
cars.
You know,
I was thinking about it today,
about,
on the way over here,
um,
you know,
you hear all like now the government
shut down all this shit and people are
saying,
you know,
the United States could default on the
debt and we could all end up fucked.
And you hear all the gloom and doom
scenarios.
But I was thinking about it and I
thought,
you know what man,
I'm old enough to remember gas lines.
You know,
I was a kid.
I was a little kid.
But I remember that.
And I remember people talking about it
and just,
you know,
when everybody was out of work,
carter was president,
you know,
I was born in [inaudible] 73.
So I remember,
um,
you know,
like five,
six years old,
shit like that,
but you know,
and it's not that bad yet.
No,
but the difference is with social media,
everyone is so much more connected now
because back then you know,
the only time you got your global fix
was at 30 minutes at night between five
and 5:30
or 6:00
when the news was on and now you can't
fucking get away from it.
It must have been so easy to run the
world back then think about it.
And they still,
they still Got busted with that oliver
north thing and that was still on tv
even back then,
which is hard to believe because it
must've been so easy to hide shit and It
still just blew up in their face.
I'm reading a book right now,
I'll call it the way of the knife and
it's a book about how basically like
we're talking about the drone shit and
to where the kind of the cia boondoggles
or the sixties,
like they were trying to poison fucking
castro and all this other bullshit.
And congress basically called them on
it.
So it was at ford,
I can't remember the president,
but basically wrote the presidential
order that says no fucking
assassination,
you know,
you assholes,
kinda no one in the gut.
You can't assassinate another foreign
official.
It's illegal no more.
And that was the stop all the bullshit
with the cia and because they were kind
of running rogue,
they're not only with castro but in
other parts of the world.
And uh,
it goes on.
And then the guy makes a pretty
interesting,
you know,
progress of how we got from that to
after september,
you know,
nine slash 11.
It was like,
okay,
well let's burn that motherfucker
because now we're killing everybody.
And so,
and that's where we are today with this
shit to where.
And what's crazy is a bush.
I was talking to a dude,
he was an instructor at a training class
I was at and a ex special forces guy did
like 20 years.
One of the most intelligent dudes I've
ever met.
I've been all over the world on
everything fucking twice.
And we were talking about.
And he goes,
you know,
people bitch about obama,
about,
you know,
he's weak on this week on that,
but when bush was in office,
they have I think 30 or 40 drone strikes
in Pakistan and then when obama came in,
hundreds were killing motherfuckers,
like it's free and he's just like,
you know,
so the guys that are on the ground doing
this shit or like,
fuck yeah,
you know,
and it's,
it's crazy though.
There's a fucking target list.
There's a list that if your fucking name
is on it and you're in Pakistan,
you're fucked.
Yeah,
right.
Exactly.
Find out Where you are.
Missiles are coming from the sky and you
ain't gonna make it.
And a lot of times fucking obama asked
to check off on that.
Yeah.
And the amount of people that get killed
that you're supposed to kill versus the
amount of people that accidentally get
killed.
Boy,
is that a shocking number?
But 98 percent the wrong people,
does it?
Is that,
I mean,
yes,
that what I've read.
I mean obviously I'm not out there
fucking counting bodies.
I'm not giving you the most accurate
readings humanly possible.
I'm getting it based on a bunch of
different things I've read online,
but I don't know.
I mean sources.
I could see that
there's a lot of fuck ups,
but it's in the nineties.
I'm going to guess that you know,
I don't know maybe,
but I could definitely see six guys
being in a car.
One of them being the guy,
you know,
there's a lot of guilt by association
going,
there is no doubt about that and there's
no doubt about that.
If they get a chance to take you out and
you happen to be with your friends,
this is a time of war and they're not
gonna miss out on that opportunity.
The certain amount of casualties that
are factored into every war and that's
just a fact of life and if you're a key
target,
that's a rap song.
We have this new thing.
It's called a drone shoots hellfire
missiles.
Hello,
hellfire missile.
Hellfire missile.
Gangster motherfuckers.
That was one of the things that
they were talking about in this book on
about how they were able,
you know,
Pakistan has been playing in the United
States since the shift began because I
mean the taliban was created by fucking
Pakistan.
I thought the taliban came out of the
mujahideen know the taliban was
basically created and by the isi.
Did al qaeda come out of the mujahideen?
Yes.
I mean the taliban is a branch of al
qaeda,
right?
No.
The taliban taliban was set up basically
by Pakistan to after,
after Russia pulled out of Afghanistan,
fucking nobody to run it.
It's warlords and wild west.
The isi,
the pakistani intelligence service put
together and backed this group.
They call themselves the taliban.
Basically.
Fundamentalist guys helped them gain
power,
consolidate power in Afghanistan.
The reason was the biggest thing,
Pakistan doesn't give a fuck about
Afghanistan,
about anything.
The only thing they give a shit about is
India.
Pakistan is scared to fucking death of
India and if we see a nuclear war and
our time,
it will probably be between India and
Pakistan is my bed,
but so what they didn't want.
If you look at a map,
where the fuck is Afghanistan?
India's here,
afghanistan's on the back door of
Pakistan.
So what?
Pakistan doesn't want,
what they can afford is to have an
indian client state and have India on
borders.
So the taliban was there a way around
that.
The taliban ran controlled Afghanistan.
They didn't run it because there's parts
of that fucking country that you can't
run.
But.
So that was what the taliban was
basically,
they're strong man that they put in.
Well they fucked up when bin laden came
in and they sheltered him and did all
this shit and they pissed off America.
So now here comes America in october of
2001 and just raise holy hell goes up,
gets the northern alliance,
pushes them out.
Well,
during all this shit was going on,
pakistan's flying fucking taliban
leaders out before they can get captured
by the us the whole time they're telling
us,
oh yeah,
go get this guy,
go get that guy.
So Pakistan has always given up the
aiccu guys.
I mean the conspiracy theory side is
that the government allowed those people
to leave.
No,
absolutely.
I don't think it's a conspiracy.
I think it's kind of everybody I know.
I mean they talked to you guys and this
is all a part of their relationship
with.
Well,
they they want,
you know,
Pakistan is not.
They'll give up the foreign fighters,
you know,
the assholes that are coming in,
the al qaeda guy,
stuff like that.
I mean they've proven that they've
captured al qaeda guys and turned them
over to the us.
I mean they have a history of that.
They have a hIstory of throwing us a
bone because they know they can't just
go.
It's going to be one of the other.
Well,
I think that there's a lot of profit in
war,
especially if it stays active and I
think the idea of completely resolving
all the issues that you have in ending
the war is not very profitable and
that's a fact.
There's look,
one of the most profitable things ever.
The history of humanity
is the drug war.
Fuck.
The drug war does not have an ending.
There's no,
there's no resolution.
It's never gonna happen.
You're never going to stop people.
Especially with the hypocrite,
a lot hypocritical attitude that we have
as a culture where we allow certain
drugs and often those drugs,
the more dangerous ones we allow those
to be legal,
but the more peaceful,
enlightening,
opening drugs that allow you to step
outside of your normal predetermined
patterns of behavior and sort of look at
the world for what it really is.
Those are the ones that are Illegal.
It's a clear sign of a society repressed
and when a society's repressed it
fucking results.
It has a freak out
to me.
I think it all comes down.
I don't give a fuck whatever the
substance or item,
whatever it is that the government says
you can't have it.
It's about,
you know,
like I'm a gun guy,
so that's my issue.
You know,
gun control is not about guns.
It's about control.
It's the same.
Jamie,
can we get some supplies?
It's the same shit with drugs.
Yeah.
And what's crazy to me,
what blows my fucking mind?
Perfect example.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm driving today from vegas.
Alright.
There's this arbitrary fucking line in
the desert between Nevada and
California.
Okay.
Now in Nevada,
I have a concealed carry permit.
I can carry a gun legally,
exercise my second amendment right.
It's bullshit,
but I have to pay money and go through a
class and to jump through these hoops to
exercise this right in the first place,
but I can exercise it if I play their
game.
Now,
if I'm standing on this side of the
line,
I'm 100 percent fucking illegal.
if I step over this line,
I'm going to jail for for the same shit.
now it's the same way with drugs.
If you got a bag of weed in California
and you've got the right card from the
right doctor,
you're straight.
Yeah,
but if you go to Texas,
they will fuck you up.
You are you.
Are you in favor of any laws as far as
like regulation of who gets firearms?
I think we've got plenty man.
Are you.
You are in favor of background checks
and shit like that?
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean it's.
I should say.
Yeah,
I mean I don't.
I think so.
Such a gun nut?
No,
I should say most people at right home,
like all the liberal freaks right now.
What?
I'm no hero,
she slept 69 on whether,
I
mean I can see it and I,
and I don't,
I don't disagree with that,
but here's,
if I could rule the world,
I would have no problem with instant
background checks.
It shouldn't cost a dime.
Like now up until in las vegas,
in Nevada,
if you buy a gun,
it costs you $25 to pay for a background
check.
Right now.
That background check consists of
someone in a government office somewhere
typing your name and the computer.
That's it.
And,
and,
and if you get a hit,
they'll deny you and then you have three
days to appeal.
but if you don't,
they say he's good.
So you're against the fact that it costs
25 bucks.
That and the fact I don't have a problem
with instant checks.
I think that's fair.
I mean,
I,
and I,
I do agree with that.
Um,
but when I have a problem with is the
fact that you loved guns.
No,
it's not,
that's not it.
It's just the fact that if I,
okay,
if I charged you,
I dunno if I charged you a fee for every
podcast you put up because you're
exercising your first amendment right
and we have to make sure joe,
that you're using this right correctly,
that you're not inciting any violence or
are trying to incite any,
you know,
you could do any damage to the
establishment.
I see what you're saying.
And so,
but to me it comes down to.
And one thing I have a big problem with
and it's something that if you're not a
gun guy,
you'd never even fucking pay attention
to,
but it's this thing called the nfa
national firearms act,
the registry and what that is,
it's,
there's,
there's these arbitrary laws that say,
okay,
if you want to own a suppressor silencer
or something like that,
or a fully automatic weapon,
whatever,
um,
you can do that.
If it's legal in your state,
you're perfectly fine to be able to do
that.
But you have to pay the government 200
bucks.
So if you pay the government 200 bucks,
we'll give you this shit.
And also you have to give up the right
to let anybody from the atf come into
your home anytime they want to check on
that.
So if you do this,
you can have this.
You can have fucking damn near anything.
I mean machine guns,
50 caliber machine guns,
you can add anything.
I know guys that have got any fucking
thing you can dream up as long as you're
willing to pay the government.
Now to me,
that's bullshit.
I see what you're saying.
I see the point.
But I also see the point that you have
to regulate.
You have to keep aware of who the
fucking crazy people are because that's
the problem that many people.
I don't have a problem with keeping guns
away from naughty people.
Right?
But you have to have employees that do
that.
They have got.
No,
that's fine.
It cost money to do so let's do that.
But are we doing that now?
We're not.
No.
You know why you can't keep guns away
from 90 people?
Because medical records are restricted.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
I think you can keep some guns away from
somebody in here.
Well,
the only way is if they're adjudicated
by a judge and there's a public record
of it and it goes into a record,
but most cases,
like all,
almost all these shootings,
like if you look at all of this is what
fires people up about guns is the mass
shootings and it's completely
understandable.
But for most part,
if you look at the guys who were doing
these shootings,
they're nuts.
They're fucked up.
Yeah.
Now,
if you start looking at the number of
people who do these shootings that are
on some type of drug,
huge,
you know,
so if we're really trying to stop,
are we,
are we going after the tool or are we
trying to stop the tool?
Are we trying to stop the act because
you know,
which one is it?
No,
it's a very good point.
I've said it many times and so,
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm probably not the right guy to get up
here and talk about what should and
shouldn't be with guns.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
I'll,
I'll be the first to admit I'm biased,
but I'm also the same guy that was stand
up here and tell you,
I think every drug on earth should be
illegal.
Yeah.
But you know what I mean when you say
you're not the right guy,
this is what I believe.
I believe there is no right guy.
I think that your ideas of what should
and should be legal or different than
other people's ideas and what you'll
tolerate are different than things are
different than people who,
you know otherwise would have no
agreements with you about everything,
but there might be certain things,
certain behaviors that you're used to
that they can't handle.
People are fucking different.
Man.
You know,
I don't think there's any right or
wrong,
but I think the real issue is a guy like
you who's not a bad guy who is a gun
enthusiast also realizes he's aware that
there's a lot of fucking bad things in
the world and I would rather be
protected than not be protected very
simply.
Well,
my then there in lies probably my,
that's your number one beef.
My,
my thing is I do not expect the
government to protect me.
yes,
it's not their job.
It's you can't.
If the,
if,
if you get robbed,
raped,
beaten,
or killed your family or you cannot sue
the police because they didn't protect
you.
It's not the police's job.
It's not the state's job to protect you
as an individual.
You can't sue the cops if you get beat
up,
if you get attacked,
if you get shot because they weren't
there to protect you,
you cannot do that because that is,
that's not their job.
So to me,
I'm fine with that.
I got no problem with that.
I don't expect it.
So if that's the case,
don't restrict me from my ability to
take care of myself and my family and
you know,
don't restrict me from having the tools
to do that and be that whatever that
tool could be.
Right.
The onLy issue is only in people who are
psychotic,
who are criminals,
who are either.
That's the only issue.
So yes,
she was.
And,
and you,
you touch an issue.
That's a big thing with me is criminals.
Okay.
Perfect example.
Most of these shootings that have taken
place have taken place.
Almost all of them.
Even if the gun was bought legally,
you know the guns were banned in that
theater in Colorado,
you know,
the military,
the shooting that just took place at the
navy gun free zone.
You know,
I'm new town at school,
you know,
I mean,
and in Nevada,
if you're a parent driving to pick up
your son or daughter,
if you just pick them up in the school,
as soon as you enter that school yard,
if even if you're a licensed ccw
carrier,
you've jumped through every hoop.
The stAte says you have to jump through
a background check,
a training course,
an actual proficiency tests where you
have to shoot your gun for score if you
do all those actions,
but yet you drive onto the school
grounds to pick up your child.
You never get out of your car.
if you have the gun on you or in your
car,
you're a criminal.
You cannot bring a gun onto that school
premises.
You can't even have it in your car when
you pick up your kid.
So now to me,
if I'm a parent,
I'm not a parent,
I don't have kids,
but if I did,
I'm going to be a criminal because of
some asshole starts to shoot up a school
or somewhere,
anything like that,
you know,
I at least I'm not the guy sitting here
saying a gun's going to solve everything
because chances are it's probably not,
but it's an option you have.
If you don't have it,
you don't have the option.
You know whAt you are,
you're a sheep.
Just hoping you don't get shot.
You know if you have an option to fight
back.
But if the state says you do not have
that option,
you must sit there and take.
You must be a victim.
That's where I have a problem.
The problem is the reality of the world
that we live in.
The problem is not the utopian
possibilities of everybody being
completely gun free.
That's the real problem with the idea of
gun control.
Is that like,
who's going to control who?
The people that abide by our laws.
Do you really think that there's enough
people out there to go out there and
find the fucking guns that are in
people's homes and.
Well,
it,
it's,
it's number one.
It's completely impossible.
If you pass the law tomorrow and said
guns are illegal,
you couldn't build prisons fast enough.
It just makes criminals out of regular
people and it's to me,
I just,
I'm of the opinion that,
you know,
you can't stop a guy from being an
asshole.
Well,
it's not even just an asshole.
It's like a rabid dog,
you know?
I mean if something like this shit is
gonna happen man.
And I think one of the two things I
think the drugs have a part to do with
it bigger than people give credit for.
I really believe that.
And the other thing is I think the media
feeds it because they give these
assholes instant celebrity and you see
this and I think these breach.
Perfect example man.
Chris dorner were you and la when this
asshole was running around?
Yeah,
he wrote a goddamn.
You know,
I knew that dude freaky shit ever.
Yeah,
I mean it was.
I mean,
I wouldn't like my buddy for folks who
don't know,
he,
uh,
I killed
the cop's kid and her boyfriend,
her boyfriend and killed a bunch of
cops,
like pulled up to the red lights and
shot up to two different incidents.
He shot up cops,
I think he might've killed one cop and
he was a former police officer.
He was fired and where lapd guy decided
he was going on in fucking rap and a but
on a,
on a rampage rather.
But he was,
he was a navy guy as well.
But this dude,
I had met him actually in a gun store in
vegas.
He used to hang out or not hanging,
I don't know if you'd call it hanging
out or whatever,
but he was a where I bought a lot of
stuff in las vegas.
Uh,
he would,
he bought shit from there as well.
Actually,
some of the shit that he used in his
little rampage.
But,
uh,
when I saw him on the news,
I was like,
god damn,
that dude looks familiar,
man.
Because when I saw him in vegas,
I always assumed he was military because
they get a lot of military guys in there
because nellis and some of the other
basis that around vegas,
a lot of military guys come in and do
shit.
But uh,
I was like,
man,
that guy looks familiar and sure enough,
my friend who was a manager at that
store called me up and he was like,
dude,
that's fucking chris.
I sold him that shit.
But here's the thing.
He went through all the legal
requirements.
Yeah.
And not only did he go through the legal
requirement of just a background check,
he went through the shit I told you
about what you have to pay out $200 tax
stamp.
But here's the other trick right now,
the backlog on that is six to nine
months long.
So to buy a short barreled rifle or a
suppressor,
so you can go in,
you pay for this shit,
you pay your $200 to the government,
and then you wait six months and it
takes them that long to do the
paperwork.
And then they send the stamp back.
It's a tax stamp and they send it back
and then you can have whatever the hell
it is that you paid for it,
but this guy did that so he can't get,
you know,
this crazy bastard went through the most
strenuous process the federal government
comes up with.
It's the process they have for selling
fully automatic weapons.
He went through that and he passed at
all and there was no way.
There was nothing in this guy's past
that would have thrown up a red flag for
anything.
I mean,
he had security clearances through the
military.
He was a goddamn lapd cop,
but he was fired from the lapd for
excessive violence.
right now,
from what I understand,
he was fired because it was,
if I remember right,
and I'm sure people,
I mean look it up,
but he was fired because his training
officer basically said he wasn't
suitable,
is what I understood was that he
basically.
Was it false complaint?
That's what it was.
He went to his bosses and said,
uh,
his partner had used a unnecessary force
or whatever.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
He's done necessary force and then he
ratted somebody out,
he ratted out and then the department
fired him because they said he was
lying,
but it turns out he wasn't like,
whoa,
that's so crazy.
They took her a regular,
like super cop turned him into a killer
with one little case like that.
But that was what was kind of funny was
the media was playing this guy up as
some kind of super trained,
you know,
he was john rambo.
But if you look at the shit he did and
I,
you know,
I'm fortunate through shooting and some
other things that I've done,
um,
to know and have some friends and the
community of guys soft guys and,
and things like that.
soft guys.
Sof is an acronym for special operations
forces.
That's kind of as the acronym that 99
point nine,
nine,
nine percent of the people don't know
soft is an acronym.
It stands for special operations forces
and that's kind of an umbrella acronym
for um,
know rangers,
special forces,
seals,
things like that.
Um,
and each one of those has their own
terms.
Like sf is special for a lot of times
people will come.
The media is terrible for this.
They'll say special forces and they mean
special operations forces like special
operations forces can be a seal team.
Special forces is an army specific unit.
It's actually a branch service.
But what I was getting back to as I was
talking,
I know I'm fortunate to know some of
these guys and they were all kind of
laughing that,
you know,
if this guy was really trained,
the lapd would be fucked because the
shit that he did do was bad.
But the way he got caught,
the thIngs he was doing is not the shit
of train guy does.
I mean,
and,
and he could have done a lot more damage
to.
I mean look at the dc snipers.
Remember that case malveaux,
you know,
elbow and that,
that kid,
and I mean they shut down dc and it was
two guys in one rifle and you know,
if this guy was literally,
you know,
if he was the john rambo,
the media was trying to play him up as
we've been a hell a lot higher body
count.
He was just just a fucking whack job.
It was a wack job to decide to go to the
mountains.
What the fuck ever gets out of the
mountains?
Whoever goes to the mountains trying to
flee from the law.
That's the worst place you can go.
You want to go to the valley sun?
You want to go to the place where he can
move around.
You don't want to go to the one place
where there's a peak and then you can't
go any higher.
You got up there and he fucked his truck
up.
Yeah.
And it was just hadley fuckers truck up
to the axle,
I guess was trying to get somewhere.
I just read.
I didn't go any farther than they lit
his truck on fire.
Right.
And left his weapons and shit in,
in the truck.
And then the crazy part though was.
That's great.
Keep it out in a cabin.
That was like literally right across the
street from the command post.
That's good moment.
That.
So they were searching all around him
and he was in the cabin almost right
across the street from the combat area
is very unusual.
You ever been up to big bear?
No.
It's a very unusual.
A lot of fighters go up there.
They do their attempts.
Yeah.
It's really good for conditioning,
but it's a strange place.
That's nice.
Nice folks.
But that's weird.
That whole.
Going back to kind of what I was talking
about with my idea of the government not
having a responsibility to protect the
individual.
If you look at the boston bombing,
you know,
these two guys with the boston bombing,
they shut down a whole fucking major us
city.
I mean they were canceling like major
sports games and shit that night.
And to me,
instead of having this mentality of
everybody go inside shelter in place,
you know,
cower and then we're going to send in
the fucking cops in their armored
personnel carriers.
And I mean it looked like Iraq.
If you look at some of the photos that
were taken during that time period,
it looks like Iraq.
I mean these guys are wearing fucking
body armor and multicam and enforce on
the streets of a us city and they're
looking for two assholes with a fucking
pressure cooker bomb.
And they shut down the whole city and
they were telling people,
don't come out of your house.
Be scared,
you know,
to me,
wouldn't it be better to say,
you know what,
if you see this fucking asshole,
call us.
Yeah,
but you call us means shoot him.
And I thought it was him officer,
but hey,
no one's going to get better that than
than coward unless it's your kid.
Hey,
better that I don't know about better
that I agree with you to a certain
extent and I agree with you with your
ability to be protected,
you don't think that it can't go the
other way.
It certainly can.
You know what?
If your kid happens to be brown and it
looked like that dude in a hoodie and
he's out walking when they told
everybody,
be inside and be scared.
well,
as if everything that we've said from
the beginning to the end,
it's.
There's no gray area,
there's no black and white and any of
these things.
The real problem is human behavior.
that's the.
What it boils down to is it's not
weapons and tools and equipments,
human behavior,
because every fucking hardware store has
an ax.
Sure.
How many excavators you hear about every
year.
Anybody can fuck you up with an ax.
You know,
guy could walk into a grocery store and
how many people could have killed with
the ax?
Free stop them.
Probably quite a few did,
and I wrote this on twitter and I'll say
to you,
your quote was perfect.
We have a mental health problem.
This guys is a gun problem.
Yeah,
and a security problem disguised as a
tyranny problem or a tyranny problem
disguised as a security problem.
I fucked up my own quote.
That's what.
That was a great quote.
I remember when you wrote that.
Well,
it's true.
It's a mental health problem.
There's no doubt about it because.
Because I have guns in,
almost all of my friends have guns.
I don't understand the idea that it's a
gun issue.
It's not a gun issue.
Guns are our tools.
It's the issue of implementing those
tools in a horrible,
horrific way.
Same thing you can do with your car if
you're so inclined.
Anybody can do.
There was an old man that,
uh,
he just,
you know,
freaked out or whatever and just ran
over a bunch of people in santa monica a
couple of years ago.
It was horrific,
horrific story,
but any crazy person could do that too,
you know,
just like they could shoot you.
They could kill just as many people in
the car much quicker,
but just plowing into a crowd.
It's so easy to do.
They could possibly.
How much damage could you do with a two
liter bottle of gasoline in a movie
theater?
Oh,
jesus.
Yeah.
I mean,
yOu know,
if your intent is to do harm,
there's a lot of weapons and hurt people
then that's it.
But my whole thing goes back to the
mindset that,
you know,
if somebody doesn't want to take on the
responsibility or,
and it got nothing to do with guns,
it's a mindset of being able to take
responsibility for your own safety.
You know?
And if somebody doesn't want to do that,
they want to delegate that to the state,
that's fine.
I don't have a problem with that,
but telling me that I have to do that is
where I have a big giant problem.
I totally understand what you're saying,
but I think there's the reality of human
beings.
It requires a certain amount of
filtering to make sure that shitheads
it's less frequent.
You're going to get a few that get
through no matter what you do,
but I think that it's not a bad thing to
just be just a little bit diligent about
who you fucking allowed to have guns and
that's fine because
I mean if it stopped right now today,
if you looked at the gun laws on the
books and that's the other thing,
you mean if it didn't get any more
restrictive and if it stopped.
all you gun guys are all like
suppression.
If it stops the day fucking crazy.
Well,
here's why is because the anti gunners,
wherever you want to call them,
they always talk about we need to
compromise.
We should.
We should come to a compromise,
but here's the compromise.
They never give anything up.
I mean,
it's always one more thing they're
taking away and this,
this has been going on since the
thirties and depending on.
I'm not a guy,
I mean on principle,
in theory,
I'm kind of,
I am called libertarian wherever the
hell you want to call it,
but I am of the mind that pretty much
anything goes.
I mean it should go and if you fuck up,
you deserve to get hammered.
Whether that's drugs,
guns,
whatever,
or
prostitution.
AnYthing.
Exactly.
Who's to say a woman can't sell her ass
if she wants to.
Yeah,
I mean as her body,
especially if she can actually get money
for it.
Exactly.
And so why can't you give him?
He can give massages.
Why isn't that illegal?
It's just not eligible.
You need a massage.
Massage is a,
you know,
just as intimate.
Oftentimes the socket,
your deck or a humming blow job through
the pants.
Yeah.
I'm a look.
You and I are on the same page with
almost everything.
You're a little more gun that he than
me,
but that's all right.
I'm pretty good now.
I understand it.
I see where you're coming from.
You know,
you're coming from the fact that they
worked for you and you don't want
anybody fucking with your life.
And that's a,
that's a rational,
almost an american value.
The idea of leave me the fuck alone.
Right?
And that's sort of slipping away
and I will stand up and you know,
I will,
I will be more than happy to,
to defend the guys.
I'll,
I'll stand up and say,
you know what?
I respect and defend the right for
someone to say I don't agree with what
I'm saying or that I'm an asshole.
No problem.
Okay,
you have the right to say that.
But where it's to me that it stops is
that when people force me to delegate my
ability to protect myself and the state
will not take up that slack.
They can not only see they can't and
they won't and they shouldn't.
But people saying to me,
you know,
you don't have,
we are going to take away your ability
to protect yourself in the,
in the name of the off chance that you
know this may prevent something and
everyone knows that at won't.
Because you know why criminals don't
follow the fucking dirt crazy.
Right?
Well,
laws in themselves in and of themselves
are very strange.
uh,
in that.
Is that a helicopter just we've been
talking to which real shit I told you
bro.
The man done got scared.
Turn off.
You're in his helicopter.
Alex jones in here right now.
He'd rattle off some statistics.
You have to be amazed.
You'd be amazed at how many people are
being watched by black helicopters.
HAve no idea,
dude.
That shit
when the donor thing was going on.
Yeah.
I don't follow Alex Jones at all.
But you follow it.
Then somehow through there and in the
way I started following him kind of
paying attention was because of that
fucking correspondent he had at the
press,
a press conferences that the cops were
doing.
Did you see that?
No,
I was fucking hilarious.
These cops are standing up and you know,
you could tell the whole fucking city of
la was scared to death and not only
that,
but the cops are lightened up mexican
women in a white truck for no fucking
because it might look like what he was
driving.
That's fun.
So I mean the whole fucking city
slipping out,
going trigger happy with the cops.
But this cops given a fucking rundown of
trying to be very precise and all this
shit and some correspondence from info
wars or whatever stands up and asks the
most asinine.
I can't even remember.
So stupid.
It's like,
you know,
how do you
say that chris dorner was a plant and
there's all this other bullshit and it.
Or was it the boston bombings?
It was the boston bombings.
It wasn't dorner.
It was boston bombing was boston
bombings.
I'm sorry,
I got them confused.
Confused the fuck out of me.
It was the boston bombings.
It was a boss.
But you remember what I'm talking about
with the press conference.
That guy standing up saying that they
were.
That's what it was saying.
They were plants saying that it was a
the guys in the windbreakers or
whatever.
Yeah,
there was a lot of weirdness when it
came to those boston bombings.
That was very weird.
There were so many people that were
crying out that it was a false flag and
there was so many,
so much disinformation to what is
information,
what not.
I'm not a conspiracy guy either,
but I was just aware of how much of it
was being perpetrated online and how
many people were getting the timeline
wrong,
so they show him these guys who were
responding and saying that these guys
were waiting before it ever happened
like that.
They already knew about it.
Like there's so much incorrect
information.
It's,
it's weird when that kind of shit
happens and you know,
that's somethinG that I really learned a
lot about when I did this.
A scifi show that joe rogan questions.
Everything's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I learned a lot about the mind of people
who just automatically think that things
are not on the up and up.
Right.
And the real issue is that sometimes
things aren't on the up and up.
That's a fact,
the fact,
but I think more often than not,
people look for it.
It's not so much it's on the up and up
because there's a conspiracy.
It's on the up and up because people
don't know what the fuck's going on and
they make shit up to fill the space.
There's definitely that.
There's definitely some of that,
but then there's also real instances
throughout history were there's been
perpetrated.
It becomes a real problem because you
try to figure out what's what.
And there's a lot of people that get
involved in these sorts of endeavors.
trying to figure out what's real and
what's not.
That will have what I call a soft
intellect.
Okay.
You know the ability,
but by soft I don't mean they're stupid,
but I mean if someone can like fairly
easily shove a new idea and them and
guide them down the path,
they want to go shove a hand up their
ass and have,
you know,
confused them to the point where they
believe it.
Some people,
they have a need in them to believe
fantastical shit that no one else has
discovered.
There's a weird,
almost like a desire,
it's almost like the same thing that
it's almost like a bygone thing that's
like left in our dna from when we had to
discover a new place that had like
better food.
We found a new hunting trail to find
these new uncovered things.
It's almost like an imperative and the
the human psyche,
so people look for fucking stupid shit.
They look for the to be the one guy,
the trail blazer,
that breaker,
and it doesn't mean that people don't
conspire,
but it also means that that too.
There's that too.
Yeah,
we got to be aware of that too because
if you're not aware of that too,
if you deny that to you really do a huge
disservice to the actual information
that you're capable of pulling out when
you look at things subjectively.
Right?
But there's
a lot of people that can't do that.
They get involved in this 10,
11,000
step game.
They want to go three or four steps in
and be rigid with their information.
They Want to stop right here.
This is clearly a conspiracy that guys
were in the wrong backpack towards his
left.
This photo shows us towards right?
And it's,
I'm doing this show.
I've realized that that's an actual,
it's like a psychological groove.
It's like these people establish it in
their minds that everything is
everything's a conspiracy and it's not
to say that some things aren't.
Many things are,
so they have some confirmation.
They get some confirmation out of
history,
gulf of tonkin,
all these different incidents,
instances,
the,
uh,
the bush cheney idea of before they left
office.
So a false flag about Iran was being
bandied about the,
the,
the northwoods document where they
wanted to blow up the fucking drone
airliner and blame it on Cuba and start
war with Cuba.
All that shit's real.
So the problem is it gets real cloudy
out there if you're not thinking good.
so if you got any sort of an instance
that happens in the news,
whether it's that bombing or this
bombing or this attack or that attack or
this,
there's always going to be a lot of
horseshit flying around because anyone
can contribute to the soup of ideas.
Sure,
anybody could throw some dickhead comes
along and goes,
oh,
nunes and fucking a giant bucket of
onions and your soup and your like
dickhead.
There was plenty of onions.
Now it's fucking onion soup with a
little bit of chicken.
That's the,
the.
That's the real issue with the
information that we received today is
that there's a gigantic soup of people
and the amount of actual real
journalists,
the real,
the original real journalists have been
replaced by these corporate puppets.
And then there's real quote unquote
print journalists who are terrified of
the new media.
Right.
And they'll,
they'll do diffuse vice.com
or have,
you know,
they'll,
they'll try to take down all the new
media and,
and you know,
and make it seem as if these people are
cretins and these people don't deserve
to be representative of the news and the
old gray lady is the way to go the New
York times as the gold standard,
but it's not the gold standard there.
The reality has been deposed false shit.
They get caught all the time and by the
way,
you're just human.
Okay.
There is no New York times anymore.
How about this?
How about you or not important about the
fucking information is important and the
vehicle for the for distributing the
information they want.
So many accolades is a current.
Any vehicle that wants so much,
so much love,
so much money.
Giant corporation backed up behind
delivering information.
That's it.
That's nonsense for you to have an ego
about past delivering of information,
things that you should have done because
that's your fucking job.
Your job is to deliver information.
You're a goddamn newspaper,
so if you get all uppity and uptight and
be afraid of the internet when your
whole fucking thing has been on
reporting shit,
that actually happens.
That's it.
It's also about.
Goes back to the same thing.
Control.
Yeah,
because if some asshole on the internet
can get on and build a following and and
gain confidence,
you know what?
There is no fucking editor sitting over
him saying,
you know what?
You might not want to say that because
this might piss off my buddy who owns
this company.
Yeah,
and that's not to slight the New York
times,
the wall street journal,
the boston globe or any of the old
newspapers in any way and not to
diminish their accomplishments in the
end to end to diminish the.
The,
the importance of them.
I at least I've read the boston globe
every fucking day when I was a kid
because I delivered it.
I delivered it from age shit.
I started like age 17 to 22.
I delivered the boston globe and at
occasionally the herald.
I read a newspaper every day.
Newspapers are fucking huge.
There were really,
really important,
but you did a job just like feeding
people was really fucking important back
then to everybody who fed people.
Those people deserve metals as well,
so the feeding people and providing
information or actually equally
important,
but the people who fed people didn't get
treated like kings and queens and
getting didn't get to fucking throw
their arms in the air and and rant and
rave when a new method of distributing
nutrition was introduced.
But it goes back to to,
you know,
the people who did distribute that
information were courted by those in
power.
Yeah.
It goes back all the way.
It always has.
I mean,
as long as there's been a written word,
but it goes and that's one thing that I
think now it still fucked up with the
new medias because how do you control
everything?
We can't control.
Everything can't control.
What you can do is marginalize it.
You shouldn't be able to control
everything.
People have to realize that enough is
enough and if you need more money than
what you're making,
most likely you don't deserve it.
That's a good point.
That's the reality of the situation.
If you need more money than than you are
currently making,
most likely you don't deserve it.
It's possible that you do,
and don't get me wrong.
What I mean by that is that there's a
lot of people out there that want.
They want to figure out how to profit
more.
They want to figure out how to make
They want to figure out how to.
But if you're really doing what you're
supposed to do,
I firmly believe that there's.
There's,
there's,
there's rivers,
you're going to have to cross,
there's mountains you're going to have
to climb,
you're going to have to figure out a way
around it,
and you might not be in a good place
right now,
but if you're a person and you're smart,
there's ways to navigate yourself around
almost every situation.
As long as you getting nutrition and
you're alive.
If you're getting the nutrition,
you're alive and you've got an ability
to think for yourself,
you might be in a terrible situation.
I understand that,
but there may very well be a way out of
that situation.
And if I took 10 guys,
baby,
only four would be able to figure the
way out of that situation.
It doesn't mean that situation is
unresolvable.
It means that you got to fucking figure
it out.
Bitch,
you got delta really shit.
Hand a cards and that happens to people
all the time,
but this is gross tendency for people to
just go,
oh good,
shoot here,
new cards and you didn't.
So you don't understand where I come
from and you have male privilege.
I think that's what you just said.
I think that is 100 percent the case in
the United States at this point in time.
If you look at people that come here and
I was thinking of.
I was thinking about coming on this
podcast and I was thinking about this
the other day and you know,
I drive.
That's one thing about I live in vegas
in the dichotomy of vegas has always
really struck me as something that's
kind of fucked up and that you can go
from the cosmopolitan hotel with people
rolling up $150,000
cars and the most beautiful women in the
world with millions of dollars that they
can spend to drive 10 minutes.
And there was a home depot with a
mexican standing outside of it that is
willing to work at whatever job you want
to give him for $10 a day and busted his
ass and or guatemalan or I don't know if
that's a proper term,
but you know.
And then we've got a guy who's come here
and willing to do nothing,
and then you got people that are
perfectly able to work,
but they've been told,
and it's not even a lot of people's
fault because from the time they were
raised up,
it's not your fault that you don't have
anything.
It's you've been fucked over.
You know it.
It's,
you know,
society has kept you down,
they've kept you on educated.
It's not your fault,
you don't have anything,
but yet you get people in.
And that's one of the beauties to me and
it's cliche,
it really is.
But to me that's one of the beauties of
this country.
And that's the thing.
This country to me is built on.
And if you ask almost anyone from that
has come here from somewhere else,
they will tell you that that's why they
came here is because this is one of the
few places in the world where you can
take yourself from nothing to something.
If you're willing to work and you want
to bust your ass and,
and understand and adapt to the
circumstances you were in.
There really is opportunity here.
And so when I hear people talk about
what you're saying,
you know that,
oh,
I got fucked over,
I got no,
you know,
I mean,
I think we both were someone to say,
I'm not.
Nobody would consider me successful.
I,
I'm successful in the fact that I get to
do what I like to do and I really enjoy
that.
I mean to me,
I make less money now than I did when I
worked for ford.
But you know,
what?
I get up and I get to do whatever the
fuck I want to do today.
Yeah.
Mostly for folks who don't even know.
We didn't even really introduce justin.
Justin runs the action report.com
is one of my favorite websites and they
put on these big time high level pool
matches were uh,
used to be.
guys would come with big backers and
now,
uh,
because of the success of it and the
fact it's been around for a long time,
now
they can actually have like,
um,
have like a prize fund and get sponsors
and all sorts of things.
And it's all
online.
Like the very best players in the world,
duke it out back and forth and yeah,
you,
you can do now because of this,
you know,
because this is really a very popular
thing in the world.
The pool,
it's like the most important thing in
the world.
The pool right now,
my opinion is no pool on tv these days
and if it wasn't for the strong presence
of the internet,
whether it's ace billiards.com
or whether it's your website,
there's not much keeping.
Like the community of pool players
together pulls a weird thing.
Man.
People don't understand how fun it is
for the people who play it.
For a guy like you were.
I was one of those things
to me,
if you're not a pool guy,
like the stuff we do,
I'm probably wouldn't interest you
because our shit is designed for the
fan.
The guy who understands the game and
stuff.
But at the same time,
to me,
paul is the world of pool.
I mean it goes back to the movie,
the hustler,
you know,
then you got the color of money,
but it's a subculture that is almost
uniquely american.
It really is,
and it's been transplanted to other
countries,
um,
but the american and my website's name
is the action report and it started out
as an idea to show the gambling side of
the game because our idea was I'd been
around pulling my whole life and I've
always loved the gambling side of it and
you know,
pool for the most part on espn.
they dress a guys up like golfers and
they send them out there and one guy
breaks and runs and the other guy breaks
and runs and they all look the same and
nobody and it just didn't go anywhere.
But,
you know,
to me,
I enjoy the action side of the game and
that was,
and it wasn't because so much of the
bedding or the guys,
you know,
talking up a game,
but because to me it comes back to a
quintessential american fucking idea of
two guys coming in,
putting their money up and the way you
keep track is by who gets more money at
the end.
I mean,
that's,
you know,
you already doesn't count.
Yeah.
It's all just in.
The beautiful thing about pool is that
that's actually the reason why it's
called pool in the first place,
like folks don't realize it was called
pocket billiards,
pooling their money together.
The bet on the game was the whole reason
why it was like the,
the chosen sport of the forbidden youth,
you know,
the glorious results of a misspent youth
is all about how good you are at playing
pool.
There's those areas during the,
you know,
max amberly,
kind of an expert on the,
uh,
the bachelor lifestyle and max everly
talks with great fondness of the
bachelor lifestyle of the early 19
hundreds in New York city and all across
the country really were men who are
bachelors would go to pool halls and
that's where they would live and hang
out.
And those are the guys that did want
settle down and have families and just
join the american grind.
Right?
and that,
to me,
pool has always been.
It's dying,
now it's dead pretty much,
but for a lot of years,
even through the war,
the thirties,
twenties,
thirties,
uh,
after world war one,
even up and through the great
depression.
But there was that they called and pool,
it's called a road player or roadman.
And that is a guy who goes from town to
town playing,
depending on.
Personally,
I hate the term pool hustler.
I fucking despise it because to me a
pool hustler is a thief,
is a con man.
He's a guy that goes in and,
you know,
tries to,
he lays down and he tries to get some
sucker,
you know,
the gam.
That's always an interesting story.
You know,
the movie the hustler was pretty much
based on that,
uh,
in pool they call it playing on the
lemon.
But to me what I like and the way most,
a lot of successful road guys,
I knew,
they didn't go in and try to play and
say they play bad.
They will go in and say,
I'll beat any asshole you got in here
for whatever you want to bet.
That's the truly american idea of it.
And it's,
it goes back to the gunfighter thing or
um,
oh god,
what's the,
the japanese swordman sorta mri.
Yes.
No,
the uh,
the guy you got tattooed on your arm
that,
you know,
the thing that people come at him and
test him.
Yeah.
And to me that idea and that's kind of
what are our site and our events and
what we do is kind of based on it was
like who is the best,
how do you find out who the best?
Well,
we didn't really even know until your
site came around because these racist to
100.
We're so incredibly rare.
Yeah.
We were talking earlier before the show
about the color of money match between
effort.
ray is earl strickland who would like
the best american player and the best
filipino paleo player for a lot of folks
who don't know anything about pool for
the filipinos in the 19 fifties I guess
when the United States navy,
the navy,
big,
big navy base,
they introduced a pool to the filipinos
and they just fuck it and ran with that
shit and now they produce some of the
very best players in the world.
It's kind of interesting
in the Philippines is this,
I mean it's as big a deal is any major
sport in the United States are shane.
There's a kid named shane van boning,
who's in my opinion,
the best american player at this time.
He's a friend of mine.
He plays in a lot of our matches,
but he was joking that the only place on
earth you can get in the cab and have
the cab driver knew who he is in the
Philippines.
That's incredible.
That's funny.
He,
I've talked about him on the podcast
several times.
Folks who haven't heard about it,
he's,
he's deaf and when he plays pool,
he shuts his hearing aid off and it just
goes into the zone.
And uh,
he also plays killer
too.
He plays about as good as anybody who's
ever played.
He's,
he has his moments where it's just
stunning shit.
And he had those moments gambling for
big money on your podcast or your,
your broadcasts rather when these race
to hundreds when you see him,
like get loose and just fire on dudes
and hit them with you had I really tight
table for folks that don't know.
A standard table is five inches.
Like if you buy one right froM the
store,
a lot of times are about five inches,
a cut tables about four inches.
And you got five and four and a half.
Four and a half.
But you guys were for.
Yeah,
for you guys were tight for.
Yeah.
And it was brutality and guys would
panic every time.
I mean [inaudible] you're playing for a
lot of money and there's not a lot of
margin of error.
And you'd go to shoot into that four
inch fucking hold on a diamond table,
which is really difficult because it has
an extra wide or extra deep shelf.
So a lot of balls that would fall on a
brunswick don't fall on a diamond.
Yep.
This motherfucker,
he's playing like they're swimming
pools.
He's just slamming balls into the back
of the pocket.
And it's shocking,
he just gets in that assassin groove
where he can't miss and he's running six
and sevens on what I mean by six and
sevens is six and seven racks in a row
of 10 ball without missing braking and
running a rack of 10 ball.
It's like nine ball.
You run the balls in the order,
but there's 10 and it's super fucking
hard to do.
And this dude is like click off with the
sound.
Just not missing.
Every ball is so precise.
His,
he gets to the point where he's got that
cue ball on a string and it's like,
he's like rolling the ball.
You,
you've deScribed it.
It's like he's every ball is just
through the bone rolls through theirs.
It's a perfect delivery.
And one of my favorite things about
shane as a player,
and like I said,
he's a friend of mine.
I've known him.
I met him in 2006 december,
2006 a long before I ever did this
stuff.
The actual import tars,
what it's called t a r a.
We started in july of 2007.
But,
uh,
so I've known shane and right now the
kid we're talking about is,
like I said,
in my opinion,
in a lot of other people's opinion,
the best american player,
he's one of the best in the world by
any,
you know,
anybody's measure.
But,
um,
he,
he's still young,
but he is a guy that he,
he goes a hundred percent every time he
plays,
but even if he loses,
he's able to take that.
It doesn't fuck him up to the point
where,
and pull such a mental game.
Uh,
sometimes.
I mean,
it's,
it's so crazy how mental have a game.
It is.
But,
uh,
he could take,
he could take his last taken,
come back was carried that.
But,
but in a tournament he can take it and
come back and win.
But uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's a subculture that to me,
there's a great quote in the movie,
uh,
the color of money and Paul Paul Newman,
if nobody,
if I,
and I'm,
chances are maybe a lot of your viewers
or listeners haven't seen that movie,
but the color of money,
if you haven't seen it,
check it out to Paul Newman,
a young tom cruise.
But in that paul,
there's a scene where a Paul Newman has
a quote and these talking to tom
cruise's girlfriend trying to get her to
convince crews to go out on the road and
he says basically,
you know,
if you're the best in the world at
something,
no matter what it is,
anything,
then rich can be arrange.
Rich comes pretty eAsy.
And you know,
he said,
and before that he had mentioned I
invest in excellence.
And to me that's what turns me on about
anything what I do with pool or any
cues,
pool cues.
You're a cute guy too,
but you know,
or anything,
whatever the hell it is.
I'm interested in the people who do it
the best because to me that excellence,
you know,
that's where the genius lies,
because anybody can do anything,
but to me it's that ability,
whatever it is,
that human nature,
that talent,
that drive to be excellent at something.
It's a.
To me that fascinates me and it's
different for different people.
We were talking about like with pool,
it's such a mental game.
I joke a lot and it's only kind of half
joking that to be really good at pool,
you've got to be about half nuts.
Just barely half joke.
Yeah.
I mean it's just you,
you,
you really,
because you have to give up so much of
everything else.
People will never understand that don't
play.
When I was a kid,
when I lived in New York,
I played easily eight hours a day almost
every day.
I constantly played pool and I wasn't
very good,
but I was obsessed with it.
And when you get to a point where you're
at the level of the high level
professional,
whether chain or african or you know any
of these top,
top name pros,
earl strickland,
you,
you have to play all day every day.
You have to be in the pool.
If you're out of the pool hall for a
day,
you fill out a stroke.
If you take a day off,
you're like,
holy shit,
I'm out of stroke.
Like guys have said that.
They took A day off and they came back
in there,
out of,
struck me.
Even there,
we're playing eight,
10 hours a day.
And
that's what's different about the elite,
the guys at shane's level is a lot of
those guys don't play that much.
They don't do that.
They'll,
you know,
they really don't play everyday putting
in eight,
10 hours a day.
Like people wouldn't think they would.
Yeah.
I mean they get to a certain level,
they understand It.
And then you know,
a lot of this because maybe they don't
have to.
But that's the difference with a guy
like shane is he does these.
And the other,
the flip side of this too though,
is,
and I've had a couple players,
we've talked about it and that is the
fact that shane is a guy that is on the
rise,
this is his ascendancy.
He's 28 years old,
29,
something like that.
It's not married,
doesn't have any kids.
So you know,
this is that,
this is,
this is his,
you know,
he's,
he's stars on the rise.
So right now this is life man.
You know,
this is what he does.
He's a hundred percent focused.
He doesn't worry about making this
mortgage payment.
He doesn't worry about,
you know,
this is old lady mad at him because he
decided to go do this or do that,
you know,
he just,
that's what he's doing
and that's what it takes to be really
excellent at something.
I think so.
And,
and every time in chains case when he's
had some ups and downs,
the downs all were related to the honey
hole sun all related to that glorious
thing that we're all searching for.
Yeah.
It's,
it's an interesting thing.
You know,
the,
the idea of excellence.
You and I agree on that,
you know,
we were both fascinated by that.
Especially we have,
we share the interest in queue.
People don't even know,
like there's a whole beautiful art to
making pool cues.
There are some.
It's a functional art art form that's
very,
very rare because it's got to have both.
Acu in order to be really revered has to
have playability and it has to have
design.
If acu Just has designed people,
don't give a fuck about it.
Like if you get a cue from like
southwest or john showman,
you get to see john.
John was a perfect example.
It's like it doesn't make that many and,
and the thing about the cues are that
they play a,
they have a balance and I have a,
a showman and it's like it's different
than any other steel jointed queue I've
ever played with and it's because
there's,
this dude just has a way of making shit.
He knows what he's doing.
He figured it out.
He knows how to splice things together
and send them correctly and cure the
wood.
And I mean,
it's a really beautiful functional art
form that's slowly being lost,
right?
And you know,
you bring up john and he's a,
he's an example of one of the things,
you know,
excellent.
Like I was talking about is something
that really excites me anD it interests
me.
And the other thing is craftsmanship.
The people that make things,
um,
whether that's knives,
guns,
pool cues,
people guys.
Cool.
Yeah.
Anything.
Guys in mostly for the most part,
people that do it,
one man shops or one or two man shops,
you know,
a guy gets.
Because I have a background,
like I said,
a machining background and things like
that.
So I have a basic understanding of what
it takes to make something,
to take it from a drawing on a piece of
paper to a block metal or whatever,
or a bunch of have been full of parts
and turn it into something.
And I know how god damn difficult that
is.
And then to,
to be able to do that at a very high
level to where you have people wanting
to pay thousands and thousands of
dollars for what you do.
That to me is one of the coolest things
in the world.
And I'm john's a friend of mine and I've
been to a shop and he's for people and I
realized we're talking about something
people don't know about or understand,
but he makes these cues and a high end
pool cue starts about 2,500
to $3,000
and can go up to $10,000.
And a lot of these cues,
uh,
like many things with high demand,
um,
if you can buy it directly from the
source,
uh,
you actually get it for cheaper than
what the secondary market is so you can
actually flip it.
And so.
And it's the same way with knives.
I'm a,
that's my new freak thing is a custom
foLding knives.
But.
So anyway,
john makes these jews out of a one car
garage.
I went and shot a did.
Uh,
did you ever see the documentary?
I did.
Really interesting stuff.
He makes these cues in a one car garage
and if I showed it to you like at a
accustomed q show that they have,
they do have um,
things like that or some just weld on
photographs.
It looks like a work of art.
I mean his stuff is just so well
executed and you kind of have to ask
them knowledge to know what you're
looking at because things were even,
you know,
things like that.
BuT it's,
it's,
it's an interesting thing.
It's hard to describe it is don't,
don't have anything to do with when you
see where it's made.
I mean if you just look at this item,
you'd go,
okay shit,
that's pretty okay.
And then you.
And then you kind of have to explain to
people that it's would you know,
this is a round piece of wood that's
tapered,
that's got big ass cuts in it with parts
of it pulled out and then other parts of
it glued back in where you took that
shit out of and perfectly.
Yeah.
And then little pieces of,
of wood cut out.
A lot of people don't even know what the
inlay is or understand it for any an
inlay in anything,
whether it's a pool cue or you see a lot
of it in jewelry boxes.
Um,
some,
some furniture has a lot of inlay.
What they'll do,
say you've got a circle and you've got
made out of ivory,
let's say,
and you've got a nice wooden table and
you want to put the circle of ivory in
it.
What you do is you go in and you mail
out a circle,
so you cut out the wood and leave a hole
there.
Then you take your piece of ivory,
you glue it in,
and then you sand it or millet flat.
And then so now it looks like you've got
a nice piece of wood with a piece of
ivory there.
Now if you take that and you multiply
it,
I think the queue you've got of john's.
I saw it when he delivered it initially
at super bowl expo.
I want to say it's like a hundred and
some inlays.
So imagine doing that hundred times.
And now here's the trick.
If you fuck up on the 99th time,
you got to start over and they do all
the time.
They'll be working on high end cues and
they'll get like three quarters of the
way done.
They have to scrap it.
Ernie.
Ernie,
as gina acu.
I did a film with him.
That's on our youtube channel.
He's had to solve cues and half ivory
handled cues.
Oh yeah.
He's,
I mean it's because it goes back to the
craftsmanship aspect of no matter what
it is you make,
you talk about cars.
I know you love cars and you're a car
guy.
You know,
you get these custom tuners are custom
builders,
you know,
if they have a dog,
they can't afford that to be out there.
They can't let that.
They can't let that car on the road.
Right.
Because one dog will fuck up 100.
You know,
you know the old saying,
you know one oh shit overrules 100
attaboys.
Yeah,
that's true.
So you know,
it,
it's,
I don't know.
To me that's the whole thing.
And the other thing about q makers that
world,
it's really fascinating is a,
those dudes are the coolest
motherfuckers across the board and the
entire pool world.
Those guys,
perfect example,
a guy we both know,
eric,
chris,
a guy who makes a very,
very in demand cues,
cues are called sugartree cues.
When we first started our business,
our,
our company,
it was complete shoe string.
It was me and my partner Chad a pullman.
We'd started up and uh,
just we had to initial partners that
came in a truck.
And jason,
I just want to mention their names
because they were important and what we
did.
But,
um,
it was a shoestring deal.
And anyway,
this,
uh,
eric,
who's become a good friend of joe in
mind,
both out of nowhere,
this guy,
he's a very,
very in demand q maker at the time.
Got a,
got a backlog of years and years.
But that means if you wanted to buy a
cue from them,
you got to wait years and anymore where
you can even build it.
And eric in particular doesn't even take
orders anymore.
So,
I mean,
you just,
if you want one of his cues,
you have to either know him or get it on
the secondary market.
But,
uh,
I was at an event,
it was 2008 and I was a photographer and
when I started my company,
I had to sell a,
one of my camera lenses to pay for a
trip.
And then for many photographers out
there,
it was a nikon 70 to 200 to eight,
about a $1,500
lens.
But we're going on this trip.
I didn't have any money,
so I had to sell this lens and uh,
didn't really tell anybody about it,
but it,
it was to me,
it was a one of those things where it's
like,
fuck man,
I don't want to do.
It's like you don't want to sell your
tools,
you know what I mean?
But,
uh,
we had made a commItment to be there and
so I did what I had to do.
So anyway,
we're,
we're in an event maybe six,
seven months later and eric walks up
and,
uh,
out of nowhere he hands me a cue.
He goes,
here,
take this.
And use it to help you guys get doWn the
road.
And I was,
I was stunned.
I,
I'd never met Him before and you know,
we started talking but,
and,
and that sounds,
that doesn't sound like much,
uh,
you know,
somebody walk out and handing you a
piece of wood or piece of pork,
you.
But the thing is he walked up and handed
me two grand.
Yeah.
He's one of the nicest guys I've ever
met and you know,
and,
and what I did was I've taken a lot of
photos and um,
I've got some photos to unique photos
because I've been in places,
you know,
the old saying about being good at
photography is f eight and be there,
you know,
I've been lucky to be there for certain
things and a lot of my photos that have
been taken.
The f eight and f eight is an f stop.
What does that mean?
Lends adjustment,
which it's basically f eight is in the
middle of the focal range.
So it allows you a depth of field to
where you can see like if you're going
to take a general photograph effect,
a good spot to be so far and just be
there and you got to go to the picture.
Yeah.
F eight and be there.
It was kind of the joke about you.
You don't have to do any fancy trickery
or anything like that.
The big thing is have a basic setup but
be there when the shot is there.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Cool.
And uh,
but I use that cue to purchase that lens
that I had sold before.
And since then a lot of,
almost everything.
You see,
any,
any one of the flyers,
any type of like promotional shit that
we do.
That photo was taken with the lens that
I was able to buy because eric gave me
that cue.
Yeah.
It's an interesting thing,
that world of craftsmanship,
of creating this really unique tool that
is very revered within the community.
What the community is like.
It's a weird kind of sketchy falling
apart community.
The,
the customer.
There's a queue collecting commune and
that's pool.
So spread out man.
And now it's even more fucked up,
but I'm pulling these is show the high
end pool cue.
Collector guys are rich.
You can't not,
you can't play in that.
You can't play in that end of the pool
and not be wealthy.
Um,
you know,
when an average queue costing four to
5,000
highend cues like old cues,
like there's certain shoemakers,
like balla bush got a lot of people have
heard of,
if you've ever seen the color of money,
the named ballot bush goes,
brought up those cues now,
eight to $25,000
anywhere,
depending on how fancy because of that
movie.
Yes.
Well,
no,
because there he's dead yet.
There is no,
you know,
he's really extreme on the end of the
collectors that high end,
high berries and bodie who is.
Yeah.
Cool level.
Who this,
his dad gestapo those cues.
Those are also like same level,
same level about bush gullible.
Oh gosh.
Cute.
Actually,
I think gus cues,
certain gus cues go carry a higher level
of price in zamboni gustin body cues
were better made.
The playability is legendary and a lot
of great players played with a zamboni
zamboni.
He's just one of those names like you,
he hear the names and bodie.
That's like the real,
like in this day and age like you here
at ballah bush baumbusch who is always
impressive,
but zamboni is like,
oh,
he's going to zamboni like,
oh shit.
Yeah,
that's high level shit.
And that's one thing.
And showman too much of more obscure
with the same level.
You know,
I think john,
among the cognitive one,
the people who know,
and that's one of the cool things is
john and barry,
sam bodie are friends and they have a
lot in common with some of their,
you know,
they like the traditional style design
work and things like that.
And uh,
so that,
it's a small,
small world,
but it's really fascinating.
And the other thing that's interesting
is,
um,
you know,
if somebody out there today said,
okay cool,
I want to learn more about these cues,
and they find out,
you know,
and you want to go get one,
you can't buy one.
Yeah,
good luck.
I mean,
you can buy one on the secondary market,
but it'd be ridiculously priced and
super expensive if.
But if you call barry,
he might take your call on and he'll be
gracious to you,
but barry's never going to fill his
order book.
You know,
he,
I mean,
I love the guy to death.
God,
god bless him.
I hope he lives to be 100 years old,
but chances are he's never going to fill
his order book
because so many people want.
It's just a matter of demand that he
has.
Yeah,
and you said cognitive sending,
one of my best accuses a joe goal,
goal cognitive.
Accuse these,
this small group of people that make
these high end instruments for this
obscure dying game and it is dying.
But to a guy like you are,
um,
guy like you were shy.
They were extremely valuable because we
recognize like if you can get ahold of
an ebony on avenue southwest,
you're like,
holy shit.
Like it's almost like you're,
you're,
you know,
you're obligated to buy it because he
realized like this.
They're not making that many of these.
There's gonna come a point in time where
you run out of 58 corvettes that don't
exist anymore,
right?
There's no more 58 corvettes and shit.
And that's where a lot of the older q
guys,
uh,
you know,
like we were speaking about the older
makers,
gus,
sam,
bodie,
ballad,
bush.
And then you have guys like john
shullman.
I think john shullman went through a
period of time where he might've made 10
q's in three years.
Yeah,
I mean,
when we talk about these guys a perfect.
Another perfect example is dennis
searing a who is arguably a lot of cute
guys,
considered the top guy.
Um,
his cues probably have the highest
resale value.
They're insane.
Yeah.
Insane.
Like a plain cubes,
like 4,000,
5,000,
$6,000
grand for what looks like a house q.
It's um,
it's an amazing thing that a guy's
excellence commitment to exacting
standards can really be,
can manifest itself in that sort of a
way.
And that's what in that way,
that's where pool cues and that's where
this,
this art form sort of like,
it,
it parallels everything else in life.
Like,
it's the same thing as like if the
beatles were playing,
everybody wants to go and see them,
you know,
it really is the same thing almost.
It's like this just this boundless
energy
to achieve excellence and that's what.
And it's in this very specific space for
this very specific purpose that maybe
four or 5,000
people on this earth will understand or
get or give a fuck.
Yeah.
Or give a fuck.
My wife looks at my pool cues and works
with the fuck is wrong with you.
It was a shit.
Oh that one's pretty.
Couldn't care less.
And I'm like,
you know,
but you know what,
that's the way I feel about watches.
Yeah.
You know,
I see guys and,
and they,
you know,
they can blow 100 grand on a watch and
love that shit.
I love that shit.
It's like,
you know,
dudes get disappointed when they see my
wife sometimes
cause they're expecting you to have some
will have a nice watch that Russell
Peters gave me.
Russell peters gave me a breitling.
It's fucking beautiful watch.
I would never spend that much money.
And the ufc gave me a rolex so I have to
legit watches,
but I'm wearing a watch.
It cost like 50 bucks.
I wish I'm bang,
I'm in this shit.
I know what time it is.
I'm not trying to impress anybody.
Meanwhile you've got a rack full of
$5,000.
My interest is not in the oppressing
other people.
I'm interested in what I'm interested
in,
you know,
like my car a 2007 and I'm not trying to
get a 2014.
I like.
I like what I like,
you know when I,
I need to.
I just need to find out what's the right
shit.
What's the.
What's the shit that makes you feel best
is,
is it this?
Is it that as a,
the watching them.
That doesn't make me feel good.
That makes me feel like an idiot.
WhY is that?
Watch.
Why doesn't it have a battery?
What?
After winding with my hand.
ThAt's so stupid.
Do you know there's a battery now is
unlimited supply.
then they stick it in.
Do you know the watches with a battery
costs $4.
The fuck is wrong with people.
Dude.
I got a um,
a timex.
What is it,
a one of those,
uh,
those ironman?
Yeah,
iron man.
I wear it.
When I went hunting,
I bought it for hunting.
It's my favorite watch.
That motherfucker gave me no problems.
Give me a little light.
I was in the middle of Montana,
you know,
like that's my watch.
I love that watch I want to use.
That's like a sacred watch to me and
that,
that watch is like the cheapest watch I
own.
But it has significance.
It means something.
That was,
that was the watch I wore the first time
I killed a deer.
Yeah,
that's good.
It means something that's kind of the
watch.
It's got guts on it.
I wrote story about a guy,
a dude.
It was a special forces team.
Guy rolls into the team room and he
showed office now.
Sf.
Sorry.
I was rolling in and he had a rolex on.
He was like,
check this shit.
And the guy goes,
oh,
that's cool.
Can you do this with it?
And he takes off his $60 g shock and he
throws it across the room and hits the
law.
He goes,
let's see you do that buddy.
Well,
this is a weird thing we're doing with
watches and cars and this is where it's
wrong.
It's wrong if you're in trying to
impress other people if you're wrong,
if you're spending your entire life
savings to try to live in the house that
everyone envies.
It's right.
If you have this idea for a house,
I've always wanted to live in a log
house.
Let's make this shit happen.
Fuck,
I'm there.
I got a log house.
Like if you enjoy the art of the log
house.
But there's a lot of people wearing
those hundred thousand dollars watches
that are just like fucking sticking that
shit in your face.
Letting you know.
It's like,
it's like bad bad.
Leroy brown likes to wear a diamond ring
and fund a heavier bat about his nose
and a bad bad leave brown.
That's what.
That's the stupidity of it all.
The stupidity of it all is not buying a
porsche to stupidity of is all of it.
All is needing people around you to
appreciate that
porsche.
Yeah.
To me,
the guy who buys the porsche because he
gets off on the history and the
performance and he understands it and he
drives it.
To me.
I think that's coolest shit.
You're fucking dentist.
Who buys the porsche that doesn't
understand how to drive a stick shift is
a douchebag.
Well,
there's the saddest thing is when I see
a guy's in nine slash 11,
I look over and he doesn't even have
paddle shifters.
She's got that automatic with the
buttons on the steering wheel.
I'm like,
you fucking slob,
blah blah,
and we're engineering or I shouldn't say
we because as I've stated earlier,
I'm an idiot.
I'm not engineering anything but even
porsche,
their engineering away from the
transmission,
there's no more manual transfers.
That was always the thing with the nine
slash 11 was that it was a fucking death
mobutu.
I mean if you didn't know what the fuck
you were doing,
it would kill you for functional.
No,
the porsche they
a long,
long,
long time ago.
Back before anybody read books,
they put the engine in the back of the
car,
it's behind the,
it's behind the rear axle.
It's a stupid place for the engine and
back then the cars only weighed 2000
plus pounds.
They only had 150 horsepower at the
most,
you know,
when they were designing these things,
they had really narrow tires and they
were really slippery.
Like if you went around a corner and
your gun,
the gas the wrong time,
your asset with totally kicked out there
were notorious for what's called
oversteering,
meaning like as you're turning the car
steers further than you would like it to
and some people out how to drive with
that.
They figured out how to walk,
brought,
brought in the rear axle or broaden the
tires,
rather stretch out the,
uh,
the real,
the rear stance,
and then figuring out how to accelerate
at a corner,
go into them slow.
But then the traction of having the
weight below the back wheels like allows
you to actually kick off quicker.
It allows you to very fast zero to 60
acceleration.
There's like a lot of good things.
If you know how to drive,
got the ass on the drive wheels so it
puts the weight over him,
but it's interesting because they
basically have spent the past several
decades trying to engineer their way
around a terrible idea and they have
another car.
Here's the number one problem.
Porsche has a call called the caYman and
the cayman's there.
You should call iT entry.
No,
no,
no.
That's the cayenne.
Cayenne.
What's the?
Cayman is a very small mid engine car
and it's a beautiful car now.
It used to be ugly as shit back when
portia had the nine,
nine,
six,
the nine,
nine.
Six was the first water cooled.
What was cheap when?
What was the,
uh,
that's the boxster box.
The boxers that came in with a roof over
it.
But see the boxster,
that's the cayman.
That's the new one.
It's dope as fuck.
But they have to keep an underpowered.
You know why?
Because it's not a rear engine car.
It's a mid engine car.
So it's balanced as much better.
It handles much better.
Its acceleration is prime.
It's beautiful.
And so they have to keep it about 3:25,
3:50,
maximum athletic.
We're talking about 3:50
is under powered.
It's powered.
My porsche has 502 years.
Our role driver.
Uh,
no,
no.
It's rear wheel drive.
I'm a savage.
I'm a man for that fucking all wheel
drive.
that's the government trying to shrink
your deck.
I saw that is they're trying to take
away your testosterone.
The rear drive is where it's at.
If you're going to drive a sports car,
especially a porsche,
it's rear wheel drive and it's a wide
body.
Shut the fuck up.
It's supposed to have a big fat rear set
of tires and a lot of god damn power.
And you better know what the fuck
happens when that 60 slash 40 gets out
of whack.
You gotta know how to counter steer so
sick in New York.
he should go naturally aspirated to stop
fucking around with those turbo
chargers.
Yeah,
they're cute and everything,
but they don't even make the same sound
like half of the fun of an engine.
what about your mustang?
Your mustang's got a surplus
supercharging.
Yeah,
but that's okay.
Supercharges okay.
Because it doesn't take away from the
sound.
It adds a little extra sound,
lads,
a little wine.
It adds that little shit.
Little fucking robo cop to the va.
It actually is kind of cool.
But a turbo charge is a real problem.
And turbo charges,
they get the full.
Well the men,
the legs sort of have.
They got rid of barely noticeable now
because they have twin turbos.
So like a car,
like the nissan gtr or the nine slash 11
turbo,
barely noticeable in less.
You'd geT ahold of a gt three if you get
a hold of the gt three,
that's the race card.
They allow you to drive in the street.
That car is totally naturally aspirated.
So my car revs up,
I have a gt three rs and it revs up to
8,800
rpm.
So it's like,
whoa.
As it's going up like that,
that's um,
that's the gt three minds at gt three
rs.
If you google gt three rs,
shark works.
I have a one that I sent to this company
in northern content.
We've got like a gt three rs and then
I'm like,
it's not crazy thing.
You've got to put some more shadow to
the baddest motherfuckers porsche
aftermarket,
and then they take it and they changed
the suspension.
Every bump it goes over.
It hurts my balls,
you know,
but I don't care.
It doesn't matter.
It's so loud.
Tell you the,
the thing you did that I will always.
And I think I,
I'm curious,
I want to ask you this question.
How much,
uh,
I mean,
I think,
do you,
what's your opinion?
I think that the car you had built on
rides the sick fish.
Yeah,
I think that thing.
I mean,
that's always stuck with me.
If you'd get that from a lot of car
guys.
Yeah.
They love it,
but I give them the reality of driviNg
that car and driving that car for a few
years.
IT broke down so many fucking times,
and I'm going to say this without being
negative at all.
There was a lot of issues in the
construction of this car behind the
scenes that allowed me to see things
that I didn't know about the car world
that mirrored the world of construction
of homes,
mirrored the world.
There's a lot of fuckery that goes on
and and unfortunately,
and there's the guys who made it,
what chip foose designed it and troy
Japan,
they built it.
They did a great fucking job,
but there's a bunch of other people
involved in these transactions that you
have to deal with it or not just
unpleasant but unpleasant to the point
where they inspiring murderous thoughts
and I had to deal with these people to
the point where I had to get on the
phone and raise my voice and I don't
like doing that.
And so There was a weirdness attached to
that car.
And then there was the fact they didn't
do what I wanted them to do.
I wanted them to make a car that I can
drive.
You know,
I wanted a car that,
you know,
they had a car that they did on the show
was called rides.
They had a 67 fastback mustang they
built that was fucking beautiful and it
was a normal lifted suspension,
normal,
normal height off the ground so you can
drive it around.
That's what I wanted to do.
I wonder the muscle car to drive around
and they made me this lower chop thing
with giant wheels and super complicated
and show tricks.
Total show car,
and I was driving into the comedy store
every weekend.
I didn't give a fuck.
This thing was not doing well.
It would leave me stranded.
It left me stranded several times and
more scary than that.
One day I came home,
I pulled into my driveway and I'm
turning to get into the garage and my
car bank leans to the side.
This is,
this is it right here.
This is what one of the few days where I
pulled it into the comedy store.
It's a beautiful car.
I still love it,
man.
To this day I kind of miss it.
I like the fact that you didn't fall
into the foods to tone trap.
Yeah.
That mother fucker tried to turn my car
into a spanish hooker.
That's just not happening.
Dog.
I love silver.
that's silver.
Color is beautiful.
It's so gorgeous and it accentuates the
shape of the car.
So I pulled into my driveway and all the
sudden the car leans to the left,
like clunk and I get out and I look in
the wheel.
Has the suspension,
is separated from the frame and the
weirdest wheel is going sideways into
the fender.
The fender is bent.
HoLy shit.
And I'm like,
I was just on the highway.
Right,
right,
right.
I was on the highway,
I was going 70 miles an hour.
We'll could've fell off easily.
I would have been dead.
I had a,
I had a three point harness and a have a
roll cage.
So maybe I'm exaggerating.
I might not be dead,
but I might be concussed.
I might've been fucked up.
I mean,
who knows when it could have happened,
it could have been run over by a semi.
Anything could have happened.
And so I brought it to this guy in simi
valley and uh,
I had mr steve troop and I had him.
I'm just put the best possible
suspension on it.
Fix it up,
make it cut all the bullshit.
What they fuck up,
fix that.
Raise it a little.
Keeps bottoming out,
you know,
like,
find out.
Find out why these bolts separated from
the suspension,
but they figured out something just
break.
It was too low.
Is bottoming out.
It was so loud.
I couldn't hear when it was bottoming
out.
It was the most ridiculously rugged ride
in the history of automobiles.
It was about.
The sound was so loud.
It was.
What was,
what was in it?
What kind of motor?
A five slash 28 hemi.
I believe it was a five slash 28,
I believe that was.
It was,
uh,
it was an engine from a truck or a crate
engine.
Jesus wasn't even an engine that was
ever offered.
I remember watching that thing.
And how long ago was that?
Man?
That was a long time ago.
It was like 2004 or something like that.
But I remember that.
I remember that show and I remember
watching that and seeing the crowd,
man,
that's,
that's the sweetest fucking looking,
but here's the deal,
man.
That's,
that's the gts,
but not a four point zero.
Put up a gts shark.
Works kermit if you find kermit my
friend alex,
as he used to be his car.
He's the one who buIlt my car and he
made thIs car called the kermit,
but he.
He had to wind up selling it.
Somebody just came with too much cash
because what they do is they take the
gts rs,
which is rennsport.
Rennsport is the most,
the most race ready version of the
porsche.
Nine 11.
They cut out the backseats to cut all
the weight.
They lower the sound deadening so that
the cage in it.
Yeah.
Mine does.
And that's what his looks like.
mine's outside.
I'll show it to you after the.
That's a.
That's the green one that he had and
that car is,
you know,
502 horsepower,
2,900
pounds and just fucking fool.
And not just the flies,
but it's like it's glued to the ground.
It's got this feel that it gives you,
when you hIt corners.
I even if I'm going 30 miles an hour,
I love the way it feels.
It feels like an athlete.
it feels like,
you know,
every other car is capable and if you
do,
that's all you're looking for.
You're looking for something that gets
you from point a to point b.
I'm not judging you.
I'm not,
but it doesn't take away.
There's some people like everybody has
to like what they like and if you don't
like what they liked something wrong
with you.
You're an asshole.
You're a fucking homophobe.
You like va.
It's everybody's got to be outraged.
Yeah.
They got to find something that
they like that you don't or you liked
that they don't,
so they don't like what they like.
You're a dick.
People are fucking crazy.
But for me,
I am.
I am madly in love with engineering.
I'm madly in love with the craftsmanship
involved and building an engine and the,
the,
just the feeling of turning the key.
What?
Boom.
F one at all.
Yes.
I love dario french.
Chetty take a different.
To the fucking wall there.
That was that.
No,
that was a big step one.
Yeah.
Let me,
uh,
dario.
No,
it wasn't.
You're right.
I guess he wasn't lamonds was it?
Indeed,
right?
It was indy.
Yes.
He was released from the hospital.
He's got that guy got an incredible car.
Well that's.
He's got a series of cars,
but he's got a 19,
73 porsche that he had rebuIlt and put
modern suspension on it.
A 350 horsepower engine.
It's like a hot rod.
Porsche is his name is dario french
chetty friend.
Chitty for c h I t,
t,
t dot.
She's still married to a no son.
Free at last.
Thank god almighty.
You know him?
No.
He was married to an actress though.
But I can only assume that it's better
for everyone.
This is him crashing.
Yeah.
Look at this.
He got launched into the fucking cage.
Jesus christ.
I lived in indianapolis and broke his
neck.
That was the indy 500 obviously.
But it's interesting to me that,
uh,
the most of the f one drivers won't race
indy because they say it's too fucking
dangerous.
Well,
it makes sense because,
you know,
an f one,
they have long straights and every,
you know,
every once in a while.
Um,
god,
what's the dude's name?
It'll come to me.
But,
uh,
anyway,
very rarely do guys get killed.
Pull up his car.
Dario french,
eddie hot rod.
Porsche.
A rarely do guys get killed in f one.
I mean it's happened,
but it's pretty rare.
Um,
but in indy they're going 200 plus miles
an hour in an oval.
In f one,
they've got turns and shit like that to
keep them slowed down.
But uh,
that ferrari.
No,
that's a porsche.
That's a porsche gt.
It's a carerra gt,
but that's not as car.
I'll tell you,
she's got a 19,
73 porsche hot rod.
Dario.
Just google that.
Tell you some shit you ought to check
out man.
And I'm not,
I'm not a biker.
I'm not a motorcycle guy.
I'm not,
not in any way shape,
form or fashion,
but something that absolutely fascinates
the shit out of me is the isle of man
tt.
What's that?
Oh,
you got.
Oh fuck.
I can't visit the island man.
Tt is a race has been going on for a
long time.
You know what the isle of man is.
Okay.
We'll tell people that don't know that I
love man is a little tiny ass island off
the coast of england.
And what they do is tee tee stands for
tourist trophy and it's been going on
for,
I want to say like a hundred years close
to it.
But uh,
they shut down the roads on the island
and they have a race course that's like
16,
18 miles,
something like that all throughout the
island.
But it's motorcycles.
It's all bikes and it's one of the only
places where these guys can go balls out
on real streets.
Um,
I'll tell you how dangerous it is.
That used to be,
I think in the seventies,
they took it off the circuit at one time
it was on the circuit of like
internationally recognized races and
they took it off because it was too
dangerous.
Too many people were dyIng over the
history of the race.
They average one to two people a year
die that race and it's.
There's,
I can't remember the name of the
documentary on it.
Just just google isle of man tt and
watch some of the footage and these guys
here.
It's crazy.
It's sick.
These are streets.
There's no barriers.
There's no runoff areas.
Nothing.
Look at this.
I mean these guys are going 150,
180 miles an hour.
How does everybody know?
Do they make sure that everybody knows
diet deal look like this is through the
mountains and shit and they're racing?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
How many people die one to two a year.
There's been over 200 dead since the
race began.
Oh my.
Yeah.
No,
but I mean look at this,
but what is this?
Because europeans are just used to
death.
You know,
they have a long history of guys.
The guys who run this race,
like you have a.
What's the shit?
What's the motogp moto gp,
which is like f one for motorcycles.
But these guys,
uh,
those guys don't fuck with this because
it's too dangerous.
Yeah.
So who's doing this?
The craziest of the crazy.
Pretty much.
Look at these motherfuckers popping
wheelies and look at the fucking camera
view.
This dude,
what is it?
Was it with the speed side?
They're one slash 70.
Oh,
jesus.
Fucking the wheeziness one 70 with just
raw body.
So anytime you fall you're dead.
You die 100 percent or you get really
fucked up forever.
It was a great documentary for the life
of me.
I,
I'll,
I need to google it and give you the
name of it.
I'm terrible with like little details
and shit.
Fucking camera on this car.
This is when I'm on bike.
Yeah,
that's a like a 300 pound motorcycle.
But look at the camera,
like when you see like what he seen.
It's,
it's a blur.
That's what's crazy.
I mean,
and where they get fucked up is
everywhere else.
Like there's a,
there's a somewhere if online there's
like a greatest hits video of the
wrecks,
and you remember that one scene where
they're going through the green fields,
the beautiful emerald fields,
and there's like a sloping turn that
goes to the right.
Something fucked up.
Guy just goes straight.
Oh,
jesus just flies.
Oh my god.
And he's dead.
I mean,
it's like as soon as he went off the
road,
he was dead.
Did you ever took him about 20 seconds
before he hit 20 seconds?
Think about 20 seconds.
That's probably why it's probably an
overestimation,
but five,
even five.
One,
one,
two,
1003,
1004,
1005.
Uh,
you gotta,
you gotta think,
you know,
the only worse thing I could think about
going like that.
Tiger's nope.
Uh,
the fucking nailed.
You see the 7:47
crash?
Yes.
That would fucking suck.
That would suck.
Being in the cockpit here in those
chains,
break the fucking cargo shifts to the
rear and you're like,
fuck,
that's a wrap.
You know you're going to die.
How much cargo is in there that made it
snap like that?
I don't know if I'm making this up,
but I want to say I heard him wraps
amwraps was that mean mine resistant
armored personnel carriers,
jews.
There were the giant asked.
They're the things that kind of replaced
the humvees.
Oh jesus.
That's.
That makes sense.
That the mass and how it was just
impossible to navigate.
If you've never seen that video before.
It was a video taken in Afghanistan.
Have a 7:47
that it's taking off and then somewhere
in the flight right after takeoff
basically.
Yeah.
The chains break the weight shifts and
it comes crashing directly and it's
like,
it just stops in midair.
It's so weird and then it just falls.
It's one of the it.
It's one of the things about having,
you know,
dashboard jeep,
a dashboard.
Cameras.
Here it is right here.
See,
they're freaks me out.
Every policy.
Insane.
It's flying.
It's crazy.
Is the dude who's taping this that I
want to say it was a us soldier,
but he doesn't say a word during this
time.
It doesn't say shit.
Rob's down and you see it,
and at this point in time,
you know,
you're like,
oh my god,
boom,
drops down.
Have you ever seen the dance so insane.
Play that again.
Please change after this.
I got another great aircraft crashed for
you.
Look at this.
Imagine being that bus.
Yeah,
like fuck.
And that's what's the dude who's taping
it?
He had the heart.
You can hear the audio because it's
ambient.
It doesn't say a fucking word.
How used to trauma is this gentleman,
I don't know,
but I mean I would be freaking the fuck
out.
Well,
that's one of the biggest issues about
these wars is bringing these young
people home and giving them no tools to
deal with the kind of trauma that
they've seen and the reality that
they've experienced and how much
different that reality is.
then the reality of me or of a normal
person who has not gone to war,
you're dealing with a totally different
type of human with completely different
rewiring the possibilities of reality
and what's fucked up is this country has
done it.
Every war they've ever had to do it
until somebody,
they can't do it.
18 world war one,
world war.
I mean it's 2000.
Twenty seven is going to be our robots
kIlled your robots do you give up and
you know.
And that's,
that's one of the things about the
drone.
I'm fascinated with the drone drones
versus drones.
Robots.
I don't ever think it will be drones
versus drones.
Uh,
maybe it will.
I don't know what.
That's when it starts getting
interesting now it sucks.
Well,
what's scary is drones versus humans.
It's not fair.
It makes it too easy.
It's like trannies.
It's like a male transvestite
transsexual fighting against female
trans.
oh yeah,
you got me.
Yeah,
I agree.
That's an issue.
There's a lot of people in the
transvestite transgender community that
believed that,
uh,
I'm a transphobia because I made some
comments about a woman who used to be a
man.
I have nothing but love for that woman
that used to be a man.
I got nothing but love for anybody.
But I am coming at anything to
completely from the point of fairness
when it comes to combat sports.
Sure,
that's it.
I could give zero fucks if you want to
be a man,
if he would rather be a woman.
There was a,
there was a navy seal that was.
There was.
Well,
there was a.
I wrote a book recently.
Yes.
A warrior princess princess.
Brian cowen,
my boy.
He interviewed one of his podcasts or
her on his podcast.
I'm full.
How do you,
you know,
I'm asked,
I'm asked pro gender equality as I am
pro gun control or pro gun ownership
should say I should usually be able to
do whatever the fuck you want and that's
where I'm at.
And the other thing too,
especially with,
with a person like that man woman,
I don't know what the proper,
it's a woman wants the trends,
but that's how I would accept that.
Any person who who served their nation
in that capacity,
I mean any person she can do whatever
the fuck they want,
but the fact of it is that they got your
back.
Yeah,
absolutely.
They have my respect as well and you
know what man,
at any kid who grows up that is growing
up as a boy but wishes he was a girl,
they have my respect to,
you know,
and there's a lot of people in the
transgender community that have been
upset at me about this,
this,
this issue about this mma fighter,
but me,
it has nothing to do with anything
except combat sports.
That's to me is a legit issue because
You're talking about,
I'm sorry,
but
this thing is not like the other.
Well
I know whY I know it because of the day.
It really isn't.
Well there's not equal.
There's variations inside the male frame
as well,
you know,
and I have experienced tremendous
benefits from being on the fortunate
side of certain genetics.
Like I have man hands a big fat stupid
man hands and if you put a woman in a
dress and if she had these manhattan's,
she'd be a dangerous bitch.
That's,
that's not fair.
It's not fair that the male frame is not
fair.
The,
the male hips are different.
Renee richards sucked as a man,
as a tennis player.
But dominated bitches as a woman,
you know,
and that's,
it's,
it's just,
it's a matter of competition and I don't
have any problem with that competition
when it comes to anything involving
anything other than physical damage.
Don't get to beat somebody up.
Exactly my,
if it was baseball and all of a sudden
this girl who used to be a guy's now
awesome at baseball.
Tough shit.
Get better at baseball.
You know,
the,
the interesting thing about transgenders
when it comes to non combat sports as
they've never achieved world
championship status.
Sure.
Like the most famous is renee richards
who became like 20th in the nation as
top level as a professional tennis
player.
That means that a dude who used to be a
dude who became a woman,
okay.
Becomes a woman,
is a woman now still can't be the best
how double x chromosome women.
Because to me it goes back to what we
talked about excellence at at any level,
no matter what you know.
So you're saying that if you had
excellence you would accept the natural
born gender that you're born with?
No,
no,
no.
What I'm saying.
And sexual identities,
or just in your mind saying,
is a genetic strength advantage cannot
overcome someone who has the drive and
willingness to be great.
That's all good on paper.
It can and it can't.
It depends on what the,
what the,
what the.
Um,
you take a per.
Here's a perfect example.
You take a mediocre run of the mill.
Male pro.
Okay.
Actually this is probably a bad example
because there's a pretty big disparity
in pool between men and women players,
which is crazy because there shouldn't
be.
That's why I needed to.
Do I need to get on the woman's pro tour
started tom robbing people.
Tell me,
can I place top 10 pro tour guarantee
you could place top 20 dad is amazing.
GuaranTee you could pay.
That's a professional.
Woman's guaranteed.
Fisher would always rob.
I guarantee you can place top 20,
but the top five would be nice to you.
But for now,
for now the iconic but a.
If you had to get beat and he got beat
by guy young kim,
there's a lot worse things.
There's a lot worse things in life to go
home and sleep,
to contemplate before you sleep,
meditate before you sleep.
You say that,
but that's.
If I get crazy,
if I get crazy and I dedicated my life
to that shit still too late.
I've got a deck.
They don't have a deck.
Feel good.
Here's something.
I'm late late.
It was great.
It's too late.
unless you involve mushrooms in the
equation,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't prove you wrong.
Every great pool player I know was
great.
by the time they were 21,
they didn't do mushrooms.
If they did do mushrooms,
they would realize that you can have a
rebirth in any point in time and then
dedicate your site,
your site,
and how kelly on that goal though.
That's true.
There's no benefit.
If there was a benefit,
if there was some fucking money,
no,
but if there was some fucking snooker
money,
if there was some real snuck her money.
Man.
Even snickers not smoker anymore.
No,
it's not a.
You know what?
Nothing's was.
No fucking nascar teams.
Presidents.
Do you want to know that?
Ford motor company just dropped john
force.
Now I'm not a drag race for us.
John force is the biggest name and nhr a
drag race.
Well,
he never reached me.
He never reached out to fuck hImself.
You,
I guarantee if I showed castrol you
would see it.
It's got too hot ass daughters to drive
to.
Come on,
man.
Don't tell electric all that.
I told you.
I like german cars.
Oh,
that's right.
You're.
You're that guy.
I like american cars.
Ever built another hot rod.
we'd never build another outline.
Yes,
I would.
they would have to be with a friend.
My issue with the building that car was.
I didn't know that.
Do that well and shit got squirrelly.
If you could build another car,
what would you buIld?
Sixty nine camaro or 69 mustang.
Those are my two.
There's something about the summer of
love that created,
in my opinion,
the perfect cards,
except for mopars.
Mopars became perfect.
It's 70 to 69.
Barracuda cannot fuck with the 70
barracuda or challenger.
Yeah.
There's something about the 19
seventies,
69 mustangs and motherfucker too fast
back.
Yes.
Oh,
it's about as good as my friend bud
breath,
man.
He.
Do you ever drive and eleanor,
did you ever find that one?
No.
The real problem is that driving is
really.
It's fun and it's interesting and
you're,
you're hopping into a time machine.
Twenty five minutes later,
you're done.
It smells like gas stinks.
He tried to take a corner of the fucking
ass and slides out on you the brakes to
lock up and leave these big black
patches when a fucking cat runs in front
of the road.
Meanwhile,
you've got this fucking ufo in the
garage over what ruined me.
I had a nine,
nine,
six,
2000,
three or 2004,
whatever it was,
nine slash 11 turbo.
That ruined me.
That mother fucker ruined me because it
was,
it was four wheel drive.
It was zero to 60 in under four secoNds
or he's the stupidest car I've ever had
in my life and I had no idea that the
physics of the movement that that car
was capable of or possible.
Right?
So I would drive like a muscle car after
that and it had a beautiful feeling to
it,
like the smell and The sound and the,
the analog steering and the shifting of
your own gears.
Like if you could get a standard.
My barracuda was actually an automatic,
which is one of the things I didn't like
about it.
But you built a car and had an automatic
put in.
It was their idea.
I let them do everything.
That's how it all happens.
Your man card suspended or how'd that
work?
Well,
it became.
I spent the money on it for sure,
but it was all them telling me I didn't
know enough about the muscle car world.
Sure.
And so when I was having it built,
I didn't know why the fuck did they put
it on a mannequin it because the amount
of power the engine was 700 horsepower,
700 horsepower is an insane amount of
money.
I mean it's an insane amount of power
and money,
but it sounds like a fire breathing
dragon.
I mean,
and he was saying that the clutch,
we just wouldn't handle it.
Sure.
It was just too much fucking a blower on
the motor.
yeah.
Oh,
jesus.
Yeah.
It was ridiculous car.
Well actually we went up.
No,
no,
no.
I take that back.
We went up going with electronic fuel
injection.
No blower.
When you have a 100 horsepower naturally
aspirated.
When you drive a car like that or like
your porsche.
I could see because like in la there's
porsches everywhere.
She can kind of slip under the radar.
People may not know exactly what the
fuck it is,
but like with the muscle car like that,
that really just stands out when you
drove it,
was it like a pain in the ass because
you have to worry about where you park.
It's like putting your dick on the
mirror and then putting,
putting a magnifying glass over your
deck and then putting that magnifying
glass,
connecting it to a,
like a gigantic speaker,
projector screens from high school.
That's what it was like.
It was.
I enjoyed kind of uncomfortable.
What?
Well,
I enjoyed the people that were cool
about it,
but I did not enjoy the people that
weren't cool about the best thing that
anybody ever said is I was at sunset and
leaving the comedy store and that was
parked at a.
There was like a red light and some guy
walked across the street and the dude
was a black dude of course,
because they just have a way with words.
He looked at my car,
he goes,
god damn,
that's what I'm talking about.
He started pointing me,
God damn,
that's a motherfucking call.
God damn.
And he walked across the street and he's
like,
god,
damn.
two more times.
It's like,
god damn,
that was almost worth having that the
bullshit almost killed you in the wheel,
fall off the wheel.
Fell off was a real issue and the other
real issue was the fact that I
understood from reading road and track
and motor trend and then online blogs.
I started understanding automotive
technology because before I came into it
as a comedian that stumbled upon some
money and the oh,
that'd be pretty to drive drive.
And you just go,
what the fuck is this?
And then I realized that I appreciated a
car that actually worked as much or more
than I appreciated a car.
That was beautiful looking.
Is that why you like the porsche robot
for our.
Yes.
You know why I like it because there's a
feel to it that it's like I know they're
not as good looking.
Like if I see a ferrari,
a ferrari four or five,
eight italia is a bound as beautiful as
someone can engineer.
I mean it might be less beautiful 10
years from now because they figured out
a new shape or it might be less
beautiful because there's a new
aesthetic,
but to me that's like as.
But who is this car for?
Is if that's a four or five,
eight italian.
I mean look at that fucking thing.
That thing is mid engine,
fantastic italian engineering and
design.
All those slits you see those with the
hood reaches the bumper and there's this
sort of triangular opening that's for
downforce and cooling and the vents
underneath the front bumper off or
downforce.
And it's a fucking marvel of
engineering.
Plus the
three,
the racing history of the f one,
nothing wrong with that.
However,
a lot of that shit is for other people
and that's where I feel like a bitch.
I personally feel like a bitch when I'm
doing things for other people.
Sure.
there's a balance between other people
and myself and I feel like that balance
is almost like a gritty old muscle car
or a 73,
nine slash 11 rs that you haven't really
rsr that you.
You haven't fucking done anything to the
paint five years.
You got chips around your wheel.
Wells age developed some patina.
You got a few nicks in your hoods,
you know queen shit going on some diva
queen shit.
Some steve mcqueen shit for real.
That's what I'm talking about man.
It's like we've gone to this manicured
nail era,
you know,
what are you wearing a wig,
what the fuck are you doing?
You know,
this is some bullshit going on where
people are there,
they're there,
they're gravitating towards the non
manly way and that non manly way is
pulling them there because of scarcity
and because it's difficult to acquire
attractive women that want to fuck you
unless you appeal to their aesthetics.
Say what,
what?
You just touched on something that I
really believe in this country is a big
thing and maybe it's just because of the
way I look at the world,
but you know,
there is a lot of shit out there like
especially modern media,
things like that.
I was per.
Here's a perfect example.
You look at.
I'm a movie,
I love movies.
If they're good.
Yeah.
And I'm a child of the eighties.
Okay.
Hey,
hold on a second.
Let's stop this podcast and we're going
to start up another one because we were
about three hours,
right?
It's gotta.
Stop.
Use your mouth to stop.
We're going to stop ustream.
We're going to come back with the audio.
I'm going to take a piss.
Justin's going to take a piss because
people have complaint.
It sounds ridiculous.
People will complain.
They go,
dude,
you know the opposite.
Why your podcast topic three hours.
We're not going to stop at three hours.
We're going to do an additional hour,
but we're going to wrap this bitch up
right now.
So the next one will be no commercials,
no bullshit,
no nothing.
We're just going to drain our bladders
and we've got more shit to talk about.
Justice and my brother.
We've been friends for.
How long have you been friends now?
Five years.
We've got a lot of shit to talk about.
I you man.
We're going to talk some more.
So let's shut this fucking podcast off.
Let's thank all of our sponsors
including a audible.com.
Go to audiBle.com
forward slash joe and get one free audio
book and 33 days of audible service.
It is something that I recommend very
highly.
I am a big fan of audio books and I'm a
big fan of audible as a company.
They've been around for a long time.
The my brother steve marmel used to have
a gig where he would do five new minutes
of standup every week and I thought
about doing that,
but I'm like,
I don't want that online and it's going
to be terrible.
It's new every week.
It could be horrible,
but marmel had the balls to do that
every week and he did it through
audible.com
and I thought that was a really cool
thing they did.
So I've always been a fan of audible.com
and to this day a fan,
not just because of that,
because of the service they provide,
the service they provide is excellent.
One free audio book,
33 days of audible service,
go to audible.com,
forward slash joe.
And thanks also to citrix goto meeting a
citrix who presented us.
I don't know how this works,
goto meeting by citrix.
I don't know who this citrix are and why
you need such a fucking hug,
but I want to give it to you.
Here's the hug.
Citrix,
go to meeting is the name of the,
uh,
the company.
And I want you guys to try this out.
Gotomeeting.com,
get a free trial for hit click the try
it free button and get free a 30 days of
goto meeting service.
Uh,
it's a special offer.
Use the promo codej r e and go and check
it out free for 30 days.
It's an excellent service.
I've heard a lot of good things about it
online and uh,
like I said,
eventually we're going to do something.
Maybe we'll do it like once a month
we'll have a goto meeting,
uh,
online conference.
We'll discuss the nature of the future
of reality while you show me your
asshole and wear a fucking guy fawkes
masks,
but until then go to gotomeeting.com.
use the promo codej r e and tried free
for 30 days.
It's an excellent service and it allows
you to have meetings with people when
you're not actually able to physically
touch them.
Okay.
We'll be right back in about five
minutes with my brother justin.
And that's a wrap.